off-premise being 114 million or 15
percent of our overall business
and you'll see the accessories are only
about four percent of our business
i mean four percent of our business
and the next slide is uh shows the
breakdown of spirits and wine by those
category types so if you look at the
first pie chart on the top you'll see
spirit sales broken down that retail
is 410 million or 90 of it
where the on premise is nine percent and
off premise is one percent and the same
in the
you can see the wine breakdown where
retail is 56 or 172 million
on premises 7 or 20 million and off
premise is
37 or the 112 million
so the next slide that we have i will
turn over
back to the chairman thank you
so on page 17 members of the committee
is marketing merchandising and
warehousing that is run by our director
lori piper
she's been with us just a little over a
year has come to us from
the private sector and has done a great
job you can see what falls under her
purview
on page 18 you can see the outlets that
we have
just in a breakdown by a map and at the
bottom you'll notice 10 stores that
are providing curbside or in-store
pickup
and that will be expanded and on in
further review
by deputy commissioner jordan when we
get to that section
fy 2020 these are our top 15 locations
in the state the top 15 stores
you can see the total down the bottom on
the right that they do
of 305 a little over 305 million
on page 19 you'll see the fy 2020 these
are the state-owned outlets that we have
they represent a little over 159 million
or 26
of our total sales you'll see the agency
stores on
page 21. at one time there was
a need for these types of stores and the
commission had concentrated on
expanding into areas where they worked
there's no longer a need with the
additional square footage that we have
and the new stores that were in place
but these in three
individual stores are licensed and
re-licensed on a yearly basis
on page 22 you'll see our new portsmouth
location and on the right hand side of
the page you'll see the
sales increase of 14 percent since we've
opened that
in october of 18. again in lancaster
opened in october of 18 you can see the
sales increase
of 47.2 percent
on page 24 you'll see the tri-city
location
this was a consolidation of our dover
and our somersworth store
and just note that this is the old dover
trolley station that was rehabilitated
and renovated to be one of our outlets
and you can see the increase of 19.9
percent since we've moved to that
location
our new outlet in tilton opened in may
of 2020
that was a consolidation of two stores
and you can see the increase of 16
in that location since we opened it
on page 25 is our west lebanon location
that was opened in september of 2019
and the sales increase of 22.4
since that new outlet has been opened
and you can see on page 27 our upcoming
outlets
and the and the dates that they'll be
open in epsom gorham
littleton concord and manchester and
there is a new one being built in new
london
as well and at this time i'd like to
introduce
uh deputy commissioner jordan to take
you through the new initiatives
that the commission is undertaking yeah
you just uh we can pause for a second
representative herbert has another
question sure
just for history uh my advertising
agency under
john sununu um ran the liquor commission
advertising
for four years so i have an interest and
a background today
i was my question was do you do takeout
we do in-store pickup and we do curbside
delivery
in 10 locations at this point and we'll
be expanding that
come the end of the month of january
so it's been a positive thing it
absolutely has
and that's part of the deputy
commissioner's presentation
representative
yes thank you my only problem is that we
need more locations
okay uh representative terry has his
hand up okay
we will have more upcoming thank you
thank you mr chairman
yes representative not sure to whom this
question should be directed
um however if we were to return to an
earlier point in the
presentation would you would you kindly
state or restate
the rationale for uh presenting the mass
data how is that integral to your
presentation i really miss that
and the second question is why can't i
buy ling ling in new hampshire
that's beer and we'll talk about uh
right
that's a separate subject all right
the massachusetts is he um
it's been somewhat of an ongoing issue
for us to be conscious of
right now of total wines um
that because they're a publicly traded
corporation
and their their mission in life is to uh
um you know is the the number one source
of selling liquor all over the place
so they have changed you know their
their they have somewhat affected our
business model
because now we have to be conscious of
where they are
where they're located in general
massachusetts
is issue of ongoing massachusetts has
been the messages since prior you know
really limited
uh to having their grocery stores
uh in the business of selling um selling
the wine and liquor
they've now changed that you know and
now really upscaling it
so it definitely has an impact for our
stores along the
along the uh on the border so primarily
fiscal
it's revenue yeah excited all right so
we got
other hands okay representative
burroughs you're next
yeah just like i i don't want to make
this a long discussion i was just very
curious i know that this goes back to
1935.
curious to know what was the rationale
for the state
overseeing liquor in an indus you know
an industry in other states that are run
by
entrepreneurs i'm just curious about
that i assume it might have been tied to
prohibition
uh it was absolutely uh the repeal of
the prohibition that if you read the
21st amendment it it it basically said
a state could stay dry if it wanted to
if the state wanted to be dry
um and then at that time uh the issue
was how do we
uh how do we bring liquor back how do we
get back um
and so each state could choose there's
model
and like i say there's basically uh the
the main two models that came out of it
was a a free-for-all
or a controlled state model and and
which we're one of those control
state models and of course um we're the
most successful
control state model uh but um
other states have struggled with it and
have and become somewhat hybrids about
it but
at the end of the day that was the
decision at the time to how we
allow liquor to be available with uh
with the minimum amount of
problems that that forced the
prohibition in the first place
thank you very much yeah representative
gleason
good morning mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen um my question goes back to
slide 10.
uh on that chart that shows the net
profits going back to the 1930s
what happened in the late 1990s to cause
the net profits to more than double
in the next 10 to 10 or so years
uh i i couldn't let the commission do it
but i believe that's when we opened up
wine sales and great it was wines in
grocery stores
but is that correct yep see i got that
one right
okay you all said you know just put your
hand down jeff that'd be great
uh representative bartlett thank you um
i was just hoping that
we'll get a copy of this powerpoint yes
absolutely great there's no way i'm
going to take notes on all of this
thank you i i actually kind of think
it's good to see it and then you can go
back and look for it when you look for
the improvement but just
follow along with if this is a nice way
to do it okay
uh jane you're up next representative
uh thank you i have a couple questions
i muted yeah can you hear me yes
christy just take your hand down
okay go ahead uh
all set yes go ahead okay uh the new
manchester location could you tell me
where that is going to be
located it will be on gold street in
manchester it's
uh it'll be across the street from the
walmart just a little bit up the street
from the walmart
and another question are all the
liquor stores on leased property or do
does the state owned some of the
property properties where the liquor
stores are
no
there's a slide up in front of you now
that tina put up that shows our
state-owned locations
and uh just one last uh question is
there a
somewhere like where i can locate the
property owners a list of the property
owners
absolutely all of our leases are
available for anyone to view so thank
you
and look at every single property owner
and the terms of every single lease
and i can just gather that information
on the web
on the website thank you very much
welcome okay got no more hands so if you
may proceed
thank you mr chairman good morning
mr chairman and committee members so
i'll take you through the marketing
initiatives that we have done first on
slide 28
is a new website that we launched in
september of 2020
with improved navigation search function
and product information displays
secondly we inserted curbside pickup
as well as uh in-store pickup
um chris could you yeah all right thank
you okay go ahead i'm sorry
i was trying to figure out where excuse
me mr chairman can i um interrupt just
for a sec
i'm going to leave the meeting um
and christina dyer from my office is now
hosting the meeting just wanted you to
know why i'm disappearing
thank you very much okay sorry
take care i knew it was coming okay yeah
okay yes go go ahead i'm sorry the
interruption thank you
um so the new website launch that we did
supported in-store pickup and curbside
shopping
but also allowed us to have the pay
online function which was
was much needed um so on the
right hand part of the slide you'll see
the curbside and in-store pickup stores
that we launched we launched two stores
in may of 2020 and we currently have 10
locations
and just under 1.5 million dollars has
been purchased through
uh that curbside and in-store pickup
function so on the bottom
left-hand corner we are on schedule to
go live with our next gen system in the
fall of 2021
that is our e-commerce second phase of
this
which would be our business to business
website as well as our d365
implementation with blue horseshoe
that is our back end system as well as
our pos system
in our stores move on to slide 29
this is just a sampling of our in-store
monthly sale flyers and displays
you can see we have very eye appealing
presentation in our displays in the
bottom of the page
and our monthly sale flyer which was
known in the past to be celebrate new
hampshire has now been
reformatted and the price list went
online
and our new uh in-store flyer is called
voila
and you can see examples of that there
move on to page 30
we have monthly sales which i'm sure
you're all aware of
and here is highlighted a number of
assets that we have
and through email digital advertising
and store posters
social media posts and placement on our
new website
move on to page 31.
this is a brand building campaign we did
for new hampshire producers
in august of 2020 where we
enhance the discount put up displays for
new hampshire wineries and distilleries
you can see that there was a lot of
social media
banner ads and we did a number of
facebook live events which consumers
uh participated in and were very excited
about
we also changed the new hampshire made
branding presentation you'll see where
it says new hampshire made 10
off we dropped the number of bottles
that you needed to purchase down to
three from six
and consumers can purchase three bottles
of new hampshire main products and
receive ten percent off
it was a it was a great program and uh
really liked by all
move on to page 32 this is just an
example of some of the social media
and email marketing we did some
rebranding
of our emails and you can see that we
have over
200 000 recipients of our emails every
single
month so instagram actually doubled
the number of followers in 2020 so
very exciting stuff move on to page 33
our digital campaign activations that we
did
obviously we had to pivot from in-person
events to online to
to address the pandemic our first was
our summer fun program which is usually
events that we held throughout the state
turned into a scavenger hunt where
consumers could go
and uh be part of the scavenger hunt
find the scavenger
hunt items and play along
to win some of our our prizes
then we had to change
our distiller showcase and winter wine
spectacular which were
large uh events for our consumers
we now change that to 90 days around the
world it's still going on it ends
january 30th we have had a lot of
players
on that a lot of people participating in
live events
with our
business partners throughout the united
states wine and spirits
uh people that are on the
events sorry um and then i'll move on to
our favorite things which is a holiday
guide that was put together
and distributed through our stores it
also downloaded on our website
which was downloaded over 960 times
and we move on to page 34. we're
supporting our community
we raised 604
2020 benefiting easter seals new
hampshire restaurant relief fund
and animal rescue league as well as
the animal shelter in manchester and
live and let live farm
as well as best buddies and we currently
have a raffle up
um participating for easter seals and
the new hampshire food bank to replace
the events that we
that i just mentioned and if we move on
to page 35
you can see since 2015 we've
nearly raised three million dollars for
these non-profits listed great
and we monitor our
our reputation we have google alerts
that come to us every week so we get to
see
what our consumers are talking about
this is a yearly roundup of those
it was uh 2405 reviews and 92 percent of
those are four and five star ratings
so thank you for your time and i'm going
to turn it over to chief mark armageddon
thank you deputy commissioner good
morning mr chairman and
and committee members it's great to see
everybody
healthy and well if
we can go to page 38
of course this is our mission statement
which as everybody knows and i see a lot
of familiar faces
faces it has a primary focus on
uh education and community safety
on page 39
we have our three-pronged approach which
is licensing
education and enforcement
page 40 you will see our educational
efforts
and our public awareness and education
through fatal choices our mobile
community outreach unit
buyers beware alcohol awareness
poster contests and presentations that
we
uh do multiple presentations that we do
throughout the state at schools meeting
through media contracts that we have and
press releases
uh further in our education efforts
you'll see license
licensee education programs uh
our managers training seminar our
brochures
education training seminar total
education
training seminar for our um
licensees servers and then
uh liquor and wine outlet training
seminars and our safe stores
we have moved during the pandemic
to a virtual platform so that there was
no pause in any of our training efforts
moving on to page 42 uh continuing with
our education efforts
for law enforcement training we do law
enforcement training for
liquor establishment security training
which is the door personnel at
our licensees establishments advanced
roadside
impaired driving enforcement which is
advanced field sobriety for law
enforcement throughout the state
drug impairment training for education
professionals
that's for your school staff um and
any education professionals that would
uh that feel
that this training might benefit them on
a daily basis
fictitious id training and drug
recognition
expert candidate school that we actually
run statewide for all the dres
throughout the state moving to page 43
liquor licenses you'll see our liquor
license types
we have 50 liquor licenses that's
debatable between
our brewpub and nano
licenses uh it fluctuates between
uh 46 and 50. um
moving down to the bottom of the page as
stated before
uh just defining our on-premise
establishments
and our off-premise establishments
moving to page 44 number of liquor
licenses
and revenue collected as you will see
for calendar uh calendar year
and 2020 uh 561
total licensees um
fy 20 revenue a
total of 17 million seven hundred and
seven
thousand eight hundred and eight
moving to page forty five uh you'll see
our education and awareness outreach
uh our 200 our 2020 trainings
um we had a total person's trained
5364 and our 2020 public awareness
events
was 29 440
and you see pictures down below just
outlining what those events are
staffing levels for sworn into civilian
positions within the division
sworn staffing levels uh you you do see
a
a drop from 2009 to 2020 of 26 to 21
sworn positions we currently have one
vacant position
civilian staffing in 2020
12 full-time staff members and currently
have one
vacancy on page 47
active licenses and permits and and
field officers
active licenses again 561
total field investigators full-time
investigators
are 15 and our licensee to investigate a
ratio
is 337.4 to 1.
uh page 48 tax collection and auditing
license types assigned
to auditing personnel uh you can see
them listed down below
uh active licensees are currently
2031 and 2020
we had have a total of three
auditors overseeing those
licensees and that staffing level has
been unchanged over the past decade
mr chen thank you chief thank you
representative
herbert has his hand up again yes chris
uh the the the ratios you just put up
licensees was it uh to one
um is that sufficient
that sounds like a lot of places an
investigator has to go to
it and and i'm i'm very proud to report
that we reach out and touch every one of
those licensed establishments um
can you always use more personnel of
course you can
but i think we're showing that the work
ethic in the division
is beyond reproach and and they're
they're doing an awesome job at
not only touching these licensed
establishments but growing
a very very good relationship that we
have proven
throughout the pandemic and that's been
our success in the last four years
one more question if i might search mr
chair
uh same thing on the auditor side i i'm
not that familiar
uh with what the all the auditors do
but having three auditors for the entire
state that sounds to me
uh us i don't know i just uh
unchanged for the past decade i guess
nothing's changed in the past 10 years
but
i'm just curious same kind of question
do you need more auditors
thank you for your question um we have
actually in this area we have moved to a
hybrid on our smart side
so our uh invest our sworn investigators
are actually cross-trained
and sometimes actually go out with the
civilian auditors
uh but again it would be the same answer
of course
uh again we are in the high 90
percentile
on in this area um there's always room
to grow
um but uh yeah it's it's
it definitely is one of those areas that
hasn't they have done a great job back
there i say back there because as the
office is structured they're in the back
of the office
but they get the uh the primary
attention of all of us
so these are these are civilian uh
people they're not uh state employees
they are state employees but they are
civilians they are not sworn
okay they do not have law enforcement
authority but they do have
administrative authority
thank you yeah i mean i you have to you
know that
all these beverage managers and wine and
every everybody else is also you also
have a federal license
um so there's no reason why anybody's
going to want to
commit fraud in terms of of their
auditing numbers
um and so we are you know we uh we we do
a good job of
you know staying on top of these
licensees and you know they do they do
file their audits you know they're
you know monthly and uh so there's you
know
the system is pretty streamlined and
works fairly well
thank you mr chairman
okay mr chairman on 49
50 51 are just some of the uh accolades
and accomplishments that the
liquor commission has received over the
last five or six years so we just wanted
to make sure that
those were listed and uh and duly noted
and that's our presentation we'd be
happy to take any questions from the
committee
that anyone might have yeah well i see
you're number three there for the
bourbon but i still can't get my buffalo
trace anymore
you know what's going on getting it
chairman so i hope that you put our
auction to uh our online auction and get
your name in there so we can pull your
name out of the hat
that's good to hear so
yes represent
all right i have a question about the
tagline new hampshire made and made in
new hampshire
did you have a difficult time with
using new hampshire made
no no when we did that we
we have partnered with the new hampshire
made folks in our stores
okay a number of times and if and if
you've noted at our highway stores in
hampton we allow them
space on both sides of the highway uh
and that space has been given to them
for a number of years
and it is their most profitable uh
profit center
so as the rfp comes out to rebuild those
stores
we will ask that that those
locations be kept in place so that that
revenue stream isn't uh
upset for for that group they're great
partners
they do a great job yeah and uh uh
another question further question being
where um
social clubs are there new social clubs
that that are being
um licensed or is that are you fit
are they are you facing out social clubs
or the state there there is no effort to
phase out social clubs
um i don't have the number in front of
me uh
our license believe it or not during the
pandemic our license applications are
up um but i don't know of any social
clubs that are
uh are in the queue right now
and uh with the um social clubs oh
follow-up
uh with the social clubs do they need to
sell
food in the social clubs to be able to
serve liquor
has that changed that has not
no so you can just sell liquor
in a social club actually there is
no there is a food requirement that
they adhere to
most most social clubs have a a
restaurant type
facility within it all right thank you
okay uh representative
thank you mr chair and thank you to the
liquor commission for your presentation
um i have a question about uh
enforcement and i guess
i guess it's enforcement and education
is that what you call that room
so in in new york uh governor cuomo has
been having
pandemic related press conferences
and he often says that his mandates will
be
enforced using new york's
whatever they call their liquor
commission in new york
that restaurants
might have their liquor license revoked
if they don't follow
the mandates is that happening here in
new hampshire
are you are you being used to enforce a
mass mandate
uh no no we have uh we have a mandate a
rule that's in place
that we work with the ag's office
and we you know that mandate has
has been passed to us that
you know people need to be socially
distanced
and they need to have mass on in those
locations
so have you have you issued any fines
related to that mandate
yes we have and is there a list
of those businesses that have been fined
somewhere
absolutely there is and how how often
does that happen how many have there
have there been so far off the top of my
head i wouldn't know but i'd be happy to
get you the information representative
yeah if you could that would be great
thank you happy to do it
and i so uh date uh
business uh amount of a fine or what
what the enforcement action was
yep that would all be good absolutely
that will all be included
great thank you
any other questions from the members
okay uh well thank you guys very much
for your presentation
uh we appreciate it um
uh we do do have some liquor bills this
year
and i just see that done uh last
tuesday you got yesterday or monday you
guys had senate
bills and uh would seem to have
got a good receiving so we'll hope for
it look forward to seeing
seeing those bills in our second half
so uh with that i guess we're all what
time is it now oh we're a little ahead
of schedule okay
um i would say representative bilo your
question about
made in new hampshire is actually has
been an ongoing issue somewhat for the
for the commission and was it was in
terms of labeling requirements and what
uh products and what they can be labeled
um and that issue has been tossed around
the time since and as uh you know help
me out
chairman i don't think we ever ever got
a resolution
of what what you can say on your bottle
of
made in new hampshire now i i believe
last session there was pass that it
would be
made in new hampshire produced and
bottled i'm not sure off the top of my
head what statute that was but we can
pass it along to you mr chairman
um because there's a lot of different
ways to to make liquor
and how to absolutely and
and each industry has its own unique uh
issues uh uh wine the question is where
are the grapes grown
uh new hampshire is not the best place
to be growing grapes
uh and i understand that nobody really
attempts to grow
red red wines here in new hampshire and
that's all imported
uh grape grape juice so the question is
then you know what where where's made in
new hampshire
if you're if in terms of you know i
guess if it's age in the oak barrels you
can prove to tell you
okay that's new hampshire enough so and
then uh we also have
a um another oddball product that's out
there for distilled
and um and i say it only because i love
the title they're they're rectified
and rectified um is that they take the
raw product um and i guess i won't
mention the name but there's a company
in salem
that makes a limoncello that uh that
imports
uh by the truckloads of the raw vodka
and then they take the lemons and the
sugar and they make a rectified product
we also have a major rectifier in
londonderry is it
might get that right londonderry correct
mr chairman
and uh so the the it's not so much of an
issue why how they do it and how they
produce it
we're okay with that uh it becomes more
of a problem and that is that we
actually have benefits for someone who
is in new hampshire
so we uh for instance when you store
your
uh your wines or products in their
bonded warehouse we
waive the fee is that is that correct mr
chairman that is correct
so so we're we're somewhat conscious of
this uh
you know entity that's in in londonderry
who is a
nationwide distributor or manufacturer
of a product
um and they are rectifying and
and uh but they are in new hampshire and
so whether we we have an ongoing
discussion about their their bonding so
uh these are kind of nuances of what
goes on yes yes go ahead jake
thank you mr chair uh i have one other
question about
out-of-state buyers
how much can and it's probably not just
out-of-state
what is the limit
of alcoholic beverages that they can
purchase in a liquor store is it
twenty thousand dollars limit per
individual there is no state law that
limits the
amount that someone could buy in one of
our stores
um said that if you spend ten thousand
dollars or more
we have another federal law that
requires us to report the bank well
there's a
there's a there's a requirement but
that's on uh
only the sale of cash 10 000 or more
we have to fill out a report for the irs
which we submit
but there is no law in the state of new
hampshire
that prohibits us from selling any
amount of
alcohol to anyone from out of state
and when they bring that product and
when they bring that product into their
state representative
they need to pay the tax in their state
that's
that's where people run afoul of the law
if they choose not to pay the
tax in their state when they bring back
that amount of alcohol or any amount
above the limits of that particular
state and each state is different
uh robert has another question go ahead
keith
thank you mr chair and uh thanks again
for taking my question
uh on the previous question i think
that's called the new hampshire
advantage right
we want people to purchase things in our
state
there's a great program where it's a
it's a bottle that's being sold at the
state store
that looks like the state capital and i
can't remember the name of it i think
it's a bourbon
and that's a program to raise money to
renovate the hall of flags at the state
house isn't that correct
that is correct representative what's
the status of that program is that
has that been successful has it raised
enough funds to
make a difference it's it's been it's
been very successful
in the i don't have the amount of money
that we raised
off the top of my head but i think we're
on the fifth bottom
uh we five different bottles that we've
done
to help raise money and there's more
is that bottled out of state that
that whiskey is from kentucky
and it's bottled in massachusetts by ms
walker
okay and the design and manufacture of
the bottle because it does look like
the state house with the little uh you
know golden
dome on top how to where was that
manufactured and and uh
how much overhead did that cost to
customize the bottle i'm not i'm not
sure
we're passed along a cost per bottle
with the alcohol in it so the breakdown
of the plus the bottle versus alcohol
i'm not sure of okay i mean i think it's
reasonably impressive thank you
and the commission and we've been doing
these bottles for
for each
private label stuff but i have to admit
myself personally i've never
ever been that good i think it's your
responsibility you have to buy at least
one right
um so before we leave i i do i i
remember that aidan is online and
because aiden will be coming in front of
the committee
do you mind um i
just introducing yourself a little bit
just so everybody knows who you are
thank you mr chairman my name is aiden
moore i
currently function as the legal
coordinator with the liquor commission
um i work uh under the direction
of the chairman and in collaboration
with the other senior uh managers
at the commission um i am often a person
who will provide you with some
historical
context of some statutes i began
my career with the commission in 1981
and
served in the enforcement division for
roughly 25 years
retiring as the chief of enforcement
and uh so therefore i do have a little
history on some of the previous
uh laws that were created along with
representative hunt we go way back
and trying to provide and provide you
with uh information that is useful
for you as you evaluate the legislation
coming before you
so i'm i'm happy to look forward to
working with you
um in the future and if you have any
questions
please feel free to contact me thank you
thank you thank you thank you mr
chairman
yeah no i yeah um just part of this
orientation is you know when people
who have questions so uh in general we
would say that
you know if people have uh on issues in
any particular bill
they should be contacting aiden in terms
of directly in
most of the issues that's correct mr
chairman
thank you yeah and thank you for
introducing a great leader
well i i would never want to overlook my
fellow
bu graduate but uh but uh aiden
aiden was around when i passed my very
first liquor
liquor build the direct shipping and i'm
happy to see direct shipping is up over
a million now million three so i know
that i'm bringing lots of
good revenue in the state with that with
that uh
awesome piece of legislation
you have the crystal ball working there
well
i was very lucky that i had a uh a
a chairman at that time who was uh at
least open to the idea the concept of it
and could see could see the potential so
that was that was a good thing but
but i would say that chairman there's
nothing like the chairman that we have
now
um how long have you been chair uh joe
uh 10 years 10 years so we have an
excellent working relationship
even though i um i will often comment
that our liquor laws are a little
byzantine
and a little confusing a little why we
do what we do you know when you hear
that
50 licenses and um there
there's there's a lot of explanation
that goes on on how we got to where we
are
um so so uh i know for for all your new
members it will be a little bit of a
learning curve
but in the end of the day um i think we
do you know we have an excellent
organization bringing in
more revenue than any other state can
ever imagine
so thank you very much mr chairman thank
you very much and the only thing i'd
like to add mr chairman to the kudos
for myself is the team that we have here
at the liquor commission
and i mean that sincerely we have a
great team
of folks that work very hard every day
in our stores
here at headquarters and in enforcement
and
we appreciate everything that everyone
does for us
to keep our business running so thank
you mr chairman
and members of the committee well thank
you all for you know doing an
outstanding job and
i still want you to you know changes
mark's title back to the old chief
enforcer i just love that title chief
the
director i don't know director yeah
i've always liked it i run two titles
i just like chief enforcer so all right
well thank you very much
and uh and can stay on i guess i have to
i don't know i have to demote you
from being a panelist but um otherwise
uh
we're at 10 10 o'clock so now we should
have securities
so um i would ask the securities
department i see barry
um would you just raise your hands is
anybody you got anybody else working
with you here barry
let me uh promote you to a panelist
okay is there anybody else barry are you
you here you have to unmute yourself
i don't control your mute barry
if you can hear me if he's there
very there you go
and now you turn up your volume i guess
i don't know
uh
you are you are because i'm not muting
you barry so if it's if there's a volume
problem
like like it's your end i can see you
now
how is that representative there you go
awesome great
all right
[Music]
your your link is very slow you're a
little choppy
at our end here
okay um
excuse me representative hunt this is
christina dyer it may work better for
him to turn his audio his video off so
that we can hear the audio
okay you hear that barry turn your video
off so maybe maybe just the audio
i hope you're at home not at the office
and we have slow slow internet at the
office
that matters all right well why don't
you just keep talking let's see what
happens
okay um
um of the committee uh
at least get the uh um
representative hunt are you able to uh
hear this
uh well just keep going maybe it's his
speed is catching up let's see
okay but yes i am uh in the office
um and it it just may be a function of
of our uh internet connection but uh i'd
first like
uh to say thank you very much for
inviting us uh
to this meeting um this hearing i should
say
uh to present and provide some of the
committee members a an overview
of the bureau and that's our our primary
functions
um just uh as a as a
general statement the the bureau of
securities is essentially responsible
for the protection
of new hampshire investors through the
enforcement of rsa
421 b are
all that is really
nation in the state educate the
best to yeah this is
this is not working nothing's not going
well barry
um do you mind just logging out and
close out your zoom and start start
afresh
okay because
okay um
well i guess if we're gonna this won't
be the first time i'm sure that this
occurs
but
hopefully um
so christina will when he comes back in
will he be in
uh under panelists or attendees because
i promoted him
he'll come in as an attendee we can bump
him back up um if the problem persists
it may be best to just have him call in
on the phone and that way we can hear
the audio but i don't know if he has a
presentation
if he does he can send it to me and we
could put it up right
right okay
representative hunt should you should
you be muted
would that help sometimes if there's
just one person that's
um not muted might interfere with the
presentation
i'm not sure i can certainly try that
but you know
if this silence continues i will fall
asleep
okay so i'll tell some stories um
so securities is actually one of the
newest of
of all our different divisions uh when
i just got elected back in back in the
late
80s um it was a stand-alone division and
then
at the time uh the decision was that
that
it should be the model the business
model should change
and so now securities is actually under
the secretary of state's office
so um so technically bill gardner is in
charge
um then so barry who is our
director of securities um is
you know obviously going to making the
presentation when we get him back here
um and the
what's interesting about securities is
that um
we have a we have a we there's a big
revenue for the state we do
uh well here okay barry's back now okay
um the panelists let's see how this
works
okay all right okay barry you're in
let's
see what happens all right okay what's
that
that's great so far both audio and video
audio and video you're good oh terrific
but i i do pardon uh
excuse me for the delay i decided really
just to power off my pc and clear out
the ram and
and uh the way to do it this all works
we'll start again again my apologies uh
to the committee
uh my name is barry glennon and i'm the
director of the new hampshire bureau of
securities regulation
uh with me here today is jeff spill jeff
is the deputy director of enforcement uh
here within the bureau
he will also be uh presenting today and
uh he's to my left but we'll
we'll just kind of move the camera when
we get to jeff
um the role really of the new hampshire
bureau of securities is essentially to
protect
new hampshire investors through the
enforcement of new hampshire rsa 421b
which is our controlling statute
essentially our role is really to
promote capital formation
uh in this the invest
uh
essentially making sure
that so your
your your computer is not buffering well
so um i guess i would ask you to just
call in you have to call it the phone
call call in um yes i do
okay all right we're gonna do
that conference just leave that alone
and call it in
and i don't know
all right so we have no graphics oh so
you did have a presentation huh
yes ouch okay well i guess you can try
you're seen to be better at the moment
okay can you see uh my powerpoint
representative uh have you have you put
it up because no we haven't we don't see
it yet
have i think that uh it may require that
you share
uh well we an understanding is you
i i have uh you you're our panelist and
i'm allowing you to share
okay i want to say who can start well no
let me put click who can start sharing
when someone else is sharing no you know
that somebody else is not sharing
so but yeah you should be able to share
okay let's try this now
all right here we go starting there we
go
how's that representative that works
that's good okay but you just have uh
audio correct uh no we actually have
visual
we can need a screen terrific for now
all right so um i'll just jump uh right
into it
because we'll be done our 30 minutes
before before you know it
the new hampshire uh department of state
bureau securities is
organized under the secretary of state's
office
uh the secretary of state is responsible
as you know for elections but also
corporations uh ucc
vital records state archives but also
the bureau of securities our
uh our primary functions as i said is
really in investor protection
uh handling uh investor complaints also
the registration of broker-dealers and
investment advisors
i'll just briefly just briefly hit upon
the major functions
of the bureau as i said licensing the
brokerage dealers and investment
advisors
is a significant task here in the state
as well as the registration of
securities products that are sold
to new hampshire residents we also
conduct
field examinations of all the
broker-dealers
investment advisors and their branch
offices which are scattered
throughout the state and to ensure that
they are in compliance
with uh securities laws also
uh we have uh outreach investor
education
outreach uh at this time it's it's
limited
because of uh covet 19 restrictions
however we have just been primarily
focusing on
radio uh type interviews uh wgir has
been a great supporter
uh with the two hour program on
saturdays and a half hour
uh with uh with them on on thursdays
at least uh four times a year and then
our our
one of our more significant activities
involves uh enforcement
unfortunately uh for those who have a
violated
uh state statute jeff's spill will be
providing you with a little bit more
insight as far as
uh some of the things that we see and
things that we do
as a bureau when it comes to enforcement
we are a self-funded agency all of our
expenses are paid through the fines and
penalties
derived through enforcement actions
however
the revenue that we generate by way of
securities registrations
um which is really uh quite significant
uh is uh uh this this fiscal year will
be we project
the 43 million dollars which go directly
uh to the general fund and we do that um
with a 12-member staff that's from the
front-end receptionist to
to the director of the bureau so we do
operate i think you know fairly leanly
although the director could use a few
pounds to lose but
we try to be lean as far as the
licensing and registration function
again
this is a very important role in that we
are really the gatekeeper for
agents in firms that that decide to do
business in the state
um they are required to
register with with the bureau
as well as any firm that is uh anyone
out looking to raise capital and doing a
securities offering that they file those
offerings
with us and we perform a qualitative
review of those offerings
but more significantly is really the
broker dealer and investment advisor
side
in terms of broker dealers as you can
see here
on the slide we license a little over
uh 1200 um broken dealers uh
now they are not all resident here in
the state uh they're
scattered throughout the country but we
do have a significant presence
clearly uh here in the state in terms of
firms
we have over 118 000 registered
representatives that we have
uh registered with us every year i can
see representatives hunt's
head shaking left and right now again
they are not all physically here
in the state uh however they are
licensed
to do business here in the state and
they reach clients by way of you know
phones
how much do you hit them up on an annual
basis do they they pay
the uh annual the renewal fee is just uh
one 100
um per licensee which is
i think reasonable we try to be
reasonable in relation to what other
states
uh also charge but there there's really
a significant number and as you can see
uh 2394 of investment advisors and
over 4 500 investment advisor
representatives
it's it's a it's a large number for a
good reason and that is
that new hampshire residing of course in
the northeast
we really are a wealth center in in the
country
a lot of people are in the state come to
new hampshire for good reason besides
um you know all the benefits of living
in the state and in our favorable tax
environment
it's really a great place for retirees
and with that you have a more older
population i think we are
in terms of our median age it's uh it's
older
we're actually older in terms of median
age in the state of florida believe it
or not
so because we are a wealth center
because we have a more elderly
population
we see a lot of assets
here that need to be managed and broker
dealers and investment advisors
recognize that
which is why we we really have such a
sizable number
now along with that in in jeff spell
we'll discuss this further
because we are a wealth center those
scammers those who commit fraud those
who violate statute
really find new hampshire attractive
because scammers go where the money is
and so we're never without any number of
cases going on
at any given time from out of state from
out of state entities
firms or unregistered uh individuals
um it it really is uh it's a significant
amount of activity unfortunately but
that's that's really what we're here for
uh we also
register a large number of securities
products the vast majority of those are
mutual funds
somewhere in the area of 15 000 mutual
funds are registered
in new hampshire and they pay an annual
fee renewal fee of a thousand dollars
per fund so it's a
significant source of revenue for
for the state of new hampshire we also
perform uh in-person audits they're done
on an unannounced basis
certainly with covert 19 we've had real
limitations and we've been respecting
uh you know covert protections for those
entities that we regulate
uh we transitioned to more of a desk
audit type of format
for field examinations meaning we would
reach out to them by phone and by way of
a video conference like this sometimes
with a better connection and
uh and then ask them to provide us
information and actually conduct
interviews over the phone
but the ideal environment really is to
be able to conduct them on an input and
in-person basis and it's really done
unannounced
so um it's it's not like as if they
could prepare
you know for the exam the exam is
roughly a one to two days
it's not like an irs exam
that you might see go on for quite some
time
we do approximately one 100 exams on
an annual basis um uh this year i
i still think we'll be at that number
given the number of desk exams
we've done and and you may ask well how
do we select
them it's not like it's necessarily just
because they were examined four years
ago and due for exam
we actually have a more formal
risk-based
um uh process for determining who
in what firm really what branch office
should be examined on a more
regular basis based upon what we may
have experienced
in a prior review certainly if it's a
new
office we will
examine them then make certain
evaluations
and it's off uh
patients you're you're you're slowing
down again
here so coming okay
no no
no
okay yeah
we also uh
this there are three
uh in which requirements to
them uh with
say five weeks on site exams of
how are we doing horrible um well
let's talk slowly i don't know i don't
know i don't know what's going on here
but i guess keep going how much more we
got of this
uh yeah like you keep freezing you keep
going and freezing
you know yeah
excuse me uh representative um mr glenn
did you want to try and call in
with the telephone and uh just keep your
your video on but disconnect the audio
so that at least we can hear you okay
good idea
so you have a phone phone barrier are
you calling yeah
yeah so what you can do is uh where you
have the mute button at the bottom
there's a little arrow if you
uh it will say um switch to phone audio
and then or leave computer audio rather
and then you can use the phone
right but he just he has to call log in
separately with the phone we call in
with the phone
uh
um just for anybody else's listening
just to remind everybody that we will
invite lobbyists to introduce themselves
at 11 15.
all right so it looks like we have a
caller um in attendees i don't know if
that caller was there before but i don't
think so
i wasn't okay so do i
allow to talk and we'll ask yep okay
is it and he's he's muted on his end how
does he um
star six will unmute so caller if that
if you
are um mr glennon could you press star
six to unmute
if that's him right right uh
i don't know it see
it's funny because it has the last three
digits i can't tell whether it's a 271
number knowing that it would that would
be a state number but
that's all right asterisks
uh so whoever is calling in in your last
three digits is four
five nine do you mind just hitting star
six so we can
oh here's another one just popped up oh
okay maybe that's it then let's uh
all right i'm gonna click this one
allowed to talk okay
so barry if that's you star six
do you unmute yourself
okay okay okay
turn the audio off on your computer
you're gonna get a lot of feedback how's
that now
that's perfect great okay so
i guess what should i leave off
uh not sure where you were um
that's cool you had you had email
contacts address
up for people i think is what i saw
i stopped the screen share so that we
would give him some confidentiality
so he'll just have to start the screen
sharing we were seeing your desktop
so you can you can start sharing again
okay
okay cool we're there
yep that's up we can see that
great
okay
uh but now i can't hear you you're still
on the phone right here
yeah all right okay so
in terms of uh audio did you hear
anything about licensing
uh well uh i we talked about licensing
and i was
remarking you know about how many
registered broker dealer agents
which are bringing in over a million
dollars of licensing them
100 bucks a year so let's try the next
screen
okay
uh field examinations uh hopefully this
is new ground
no you did exist yeah i don't know if it
could be heard actually uh
on audits okay
okay so we do conduct uh field audits of
our broker dealer offices and investment
advisory offices
uh they are done typically on a
unannounced basis
uh because of covid we've had some
restrictions clearly being able to visit
those offices
but have reverted have reverted to desk
examinations which
are effective we took the low risk
entities and
examined them rather than what we would
deem some of the higher risk
offices around the state
that has been going uh very well but
otherwise they're typically done
on an unannounced basis to determine
whether they have actually
complied uh with securities laws
including disclosure
review of client files for product
suitability and
and a number of other metrics that we
actually look at
but we do a little over typically on a
good year over 100
exams with two examiners
we're also responsible for the oversight
of risk pools
pursuant to rsa 5b there are three such
pools
in the state health trust new hampshire
being one of the largest ones
they have certain annual financial
filings
and also also actuarial filings that are
made with the secretary of state's
office each year
and we monitor those uh we look at those
as well as
do in-person examinations uh of
of the risk pools
but our one of our uh more significant
functions really is uh you know
protection of new hampshire investors
and responding to
those who may have been harmed by either
one of our licensees or
unlicensed individuals that
are trying to commit fraud or any form
of misrepresentation
to new hampshire investors jeff spill
is our deputy director of enforcement
he's here unfortunately because of
of video issues i i can't portray him
there at least i don't know if i can i
don't care i don't want to lose our
signal
but uh jeff has been uh with the bureau
for a little over 21 years now at this
point
uh and uh has been deputy
director of enforcement for that entire
period so i'll turn it over to jeff
to talk a little bit about what we do in
that area
jeff good morning and thank you for this
opportunity to address the committee
as barry said i'm in charge of
enforcement and
the two main ways we start an
enforcement matter is through a
written complaint or a complaint by a
resident of the state of new hampshire
we can also get complaints from out of
state individuals who do business in new
hampshire
or if the transaction occurred in new
hampshire and the other way is through
investigations that we initiate on our
own
the statute 421b has sweeping
authority for us to conduct
investigations
accumulate evidence take testimony under
oath
and the culmination of that if we
determine that
the statute has been violated is we have
a hearings process
which is headed up by a hearings
examiner appointed by the secretary of
state usually
somebody from our office and uh the
decisions that are made
can render sanctions which range from
restitution paid to the harmed investor
discouragement of ill-gotten gains
administrative fines
and costs of our investigation are the
primary
tools we utilize we can also bar
individuals
firms and and agents that have violated
the law
typically we get about 70 complaints and
uh investigations uh we
usually uh bring about
half of those as actual enforcement
matters
uh the other half we would close as as
uh
not actionable either because there's a
lack of evidence or
maybe some other reason that precludes
us from going forward
we also are short of actually
bringing enforcement action can provide
assistance to the public
on questions of uh
need for the for the individual it could
be a question about their account it
could be a problem they're having
with an agent or a firm it could be
um you know just having them uh
a particular issue that they want to see
resolved
so we've kind of pride ourselves in
being an open door
policy for enforcement action and for
enforcing the statutes we don't turn
away any complaints we don't
foreclose anybody due to dollar amounts
or
due to whether or not there's another
agency investigating
and we handle basically all issues that
come before us in one way or another
we also work with other agencies on a
parallel basis
or on a global basis we work with the
department of justice
state of new hampshire department of
justice united states
the local county prosecutors we do not
have criminal authority we have
civil authority so we can work with
criminal agencies to bring criminal
charges
we also work with our securities
industry counterparts
which is finra the self-regulatory
organization
and the securities and exchange
commission which is our federal
counterpart
um you may be interested to know how
covert has affected
enforcement and we've been able to
navigate through that very effectively
been able to
keep up our number of actions we've been
able to keep up
our sanctioning power we have
done hearings and taken testimony
remotely
to satisfy social distancing
and keep people safe with respect to
other enforcement type issues that we
deal with
there is a new statute online called
financial exploitation of vulnerable
doubts
that has been put in place to
protect vulnerable adults from scammers
in the sense that scammers can gain
access
illegal access to their accounts or
through their scam deceive vulnerable
adults
in uh either believing that they are
dealing with a real person or a real
firm
or real securities transaction when it's
actually fraudulent
and the way we can effectively do that
is not only through the enforcement
process
but the statute allows the account to be
frozen
by the firm so that money can't be
withdrawn
or so that funds are stabilized
and access is denied to the funds and so
such time as the bureau can determine
whether there's an enforcement action
that needs to be taken
or safety precautions put in place we
also
bring what we call global enforcement
issues
along with other states and in canadian
provinces
that is headed up by a national
organization
which is the north american securities
administrators association
and members are of our staff are also
very active with nasa
taking various roles um and enforcement
committees
underneath uh the nasa uh corporate
office
um some of the scams that we encounter
that have been a far far reaching impact
nationally romance scams where
individuals pose
vulnerable doubts as a romantic interest
and through that romantic interest drain
or withdraw funds illegally from the
account
uh phony securities deals uh where the
securities product
doesn't exist or doesn't do what is
promised
uh phony securities
products that aren't that don't exist
or phony securities firms that don't
actually exist
and a lot of this now is unfortunately
perpetrated on the internet
where people can log on and believe that
they're dealing with actual people
and actual firms when they're really
scammers posing as such
and that's um essentially
my presentation on enforcement
thank you jeff uh i'd also just like to
point
out that the bureau has been operational
in person here at the state house annex
i think since may we were out for a
brief period about six weeks but then
returned to the annex we are located on
the third floor
um so if you ever are in concord uh we
can
there are certain protections that can
be taken uh for you to be able to
actually come in
and uh and meet with us uh if you want
to hear more about
the bureau certainly i think the
presentation and unfortunately
technology has
uh maybe given you a very chopped
version of what we do and i
sincerely apologize for that uh we'll do
what we can to correct
uh to correct that in the future uh but
we are available uh to meet with
any members of the committee uh um as we
go forward we do not have any bills
um that will be that we intend to bring
or have
someone sponsored before commerce
however there may be
you know some other bills for which we
have an interest in so we'll be able to
you know see you hopefully in person at
some point uh so
mr chair i'd turn it back to you if you
have any questions or
any members of the committee okay yeah
so just uh take your share screen
down so that i can see all my members
and
and um and then we can is there anybody
have
have a question
[Music]
i don't see any hands up so um
so i think we're good so okay well thank
you very much and members of the
committee
actually does kevin want you just kevin
around or kevin
uh kevin unfortunately had a hearing
that he had to attend
uh he was slated however we did cover
the licensing component
uh in field exams which he is
responsible for right which he has been
in front of the committee several times
yes he's also our the legislative
liaison with the committee
there you go so all right uh with that
uh well thank you very much
sorry about the the bugs but that's the
reason why we're doing this to try to
iron these bugs out
ahead of time so all right thank you
very much
and uh nice talking to you um yeah
christy did you want to
oh you're just you want to say goodbye
okay okay thank you very much
all right so 10 35 so we're now
going back to and again i'm going to
remind lobbyists at 11 15
and so now i'm asking um
tom uh tom or brandon if you guys are
there just raise your hand so i can find
you
on the attendees list all right there's
tom
alright tom i'm promoting to a panelist
and brandon i am promoting you to a
panelist
okay so we'll start off um under the
attorney general's office there are many
different things there but there are two
divisions that
um that we are uh their regulator so
um why don't you go ahead um we'll start
start with tom right we have tom first
uh from charitable trust
great um thank you uh mr chairman
and hello to well uh members of the
committee i recognize a number of you
um from past sessions and uh
glad to see you on board again this year
um
my name is tom donovan i'm the director
of charitable trusts
in the attorney general's office and
um we're a a small corner of the
attorney general's office
but we're proud of the work that we do
um in 1943 new hampshire
became the first state to create an
office dedicated
to the oversight of charitable trusts
and organizations
um historically attorney general's
office
have oversight responsibility with
respect to charitable assets it goes all
the way back to
queen elizabeth the first in 1601
but for better or worse attorney
general's office
kind of had it on the back burner for
many years but in 1943
new hampshire's legislature said we need
to
pay attention to the assets that people
have left in their wills and trusts etc
for charitable purposes and maybe aren't
being
used the way they are supposed to be
so our office
[Music]
requires uh charitable trusts charitable
organizations
to register with us and to file annual
reports
those annual reports include a financial
statement they include a list of the
board of directors
and they include a conflict of interest
statement
all of that information is available
to the public unfortunately um
we don't have all of that information
posted online i'd love to be able to do
that the way you
the secretary of state does it and
someday we will
we are moving um and hopefully within
the next month we'll allow our charities
to file
these forms electronically uh which will
make things a lot easier for them
um the next step after that will be to
get the information posted
so that the public will be able to see
that
we have about 11 000 organizations
um charitable organizations that report
to us
every year about two-thirds of those
let's say around 6 500 of them
are based here in new hampshire
the others are out-of-state
organizations that either offer services
here
or are raising money from the public in
new hampshire
we have a set of eyes that reviews every
one
of the 11 000 annual reports that come
in
and we'll get back to organizations if
they have if we have issues with them
and if there's a problem that emerges we
will
begin an investigation and
uh we have the authority to sabina folks
and bring them in
and uh may uh
conduct enforcement activities if
necessary
we want to make sure that the people who
are donating money
um or uh have contracts with the state
government
uh are in fact uh being well served
by dealing with charitable organizations
and
and we're also we we like to say we
would rather educate
than regulate we recognize that these
are volunteer
board members that are governing the
organization
and they're doing it uh nights and
weekends
and so we again we'd rather
educate them than regulate them and so
we
we come at it with that um
viewpoint we want to promote the uh
growth and prosperity of the nonprofit
sector in new hampshire because it is
very
important and it it includes everything
from your local historical society
your local little league all the way up
to
dartmouth college and the hospitals
on the on the higher side now
churches are exempt from reporting to us
uh however to the extent that churches
hold
restricted funds endowments we do have
oversight there
to make sure that the donors who may
have left money
for a particular restricted purpose that
that restriction is honored
we have a couple of other activities
that we perform
in in our charitable trust unit
healthcare acquisition transactions and
you
probably know something about that it
seems that every hospital in the state
wants to merge with every other hospital
in the state
so that for the past five years we've
been very busy
we review those transactions
with an eye towards seeing whether the
board of directors conducted adequate
due diligence
was it in the best interest of the
hospital itself
and is it in the best interest of the
communities they serve
sometimes um the result of our review
is that we'll we will let the or
the uh transaction go forward but we'll
put some conditions on
it or we may object to it
and we have some that are pending now
but uh over half of the hospitals in the
state
have gone through some type of
transaction that we've reviewed over the
past
five years and and the activity
continues
another area we look at are conservation
easement
amendments most people when they don't
when the
when conservation easements get created
on a parcel of land let's say somebody
has 40 acres of woodlands or
40 acres of farmland they might donate
it or
have a bargain sale to a conservation
organization
um and then a few years down the road
maybe the
the the landowner gets
second thoughts and and says well wait a
minute you know maybe i do want to put
another house on that property or
gee maybe i do want to
start you know having weddings in the
barn or something like that
and um so we have a process to review
those in some cases they may need to
take a trip
to court but the the bottom line is
if if somebody's donated a conservation
easement saying that they'll never
develop their property
um you can't take that back um
and and it's the obligation of the uh
conservation organization to enforce
that that that's why they hold it
um we also um
require the registration of
professional fundraisers folks who do
who make those fun time dinner phone
calls to you
asking to donate money to the police
relief association
or a conservation group etc um
they have a first amendment right to do
that uh but we require them to register
we
we want to see what the script is that
they're that they are
um giving out
when they're calling people and we
require a bond
from that and we do occasionally uh
investigate those organizations and and
there are some scam charities out there
and we've shut them down
together with offices like ours in other
states
we also um require the uh
notices of charitable gift annuities
that that um
uh charities offer and there may be a
bill relating to that
uh in front of your committee i haven't
looked at the text of it but
there might be something that will come
before your committee relating
to that um so that's the sort of work
that we
do um and uh if i were to say is there
is there a trend that you're paying
attention to i would say
it's online giving um
you know you know people set up gofundme
campaigns
uh a lot and that's great um
if people set up a gofundme campaign to
help pay their own medical bills or
their pets medical bills etc
that is not charity in the
technical sense it's giving from by one
individual to another individual is not
charity that is uh governed by us
so we don't review that but
a lot of charities have also found that
online giving is a very efficient way to
raise
money and the cost of doing so is much
better than
than hiring those paid fundraisers so we
encourage
charities to be using online giving
they just need to be careful in how it's
done
and um you know you have campaigns like
amazon smiles
paypal giving fund other ways that
people can give
and there's a lot of creativity out
there we're
thinking that we don't have a lot of
ways to
keep an eye on it we don't want to
discourage that kind of giving
but there have been some abuses and so
i'm not saying this year but but in some
year in the future there might be
something
some legislation for this committee to
consider that will
mainly make it clear to the public when
they're giving
what the what the fees are that the
platforms are taking out
who's really getting the money etc so
that's the sort of thing we're looking
at
but certainly making sure that people
know it's not tax deductible
you know if it's not a 501 c 3 you're
you're you're giving money you're not
don't try to get a donation well and
yeah no that's absolutely right
uh uh sherman so if you give if i put
up a campaign on gofundme for you to
pay the veterinary bills for my dog
um you can't deduct that off of your
taxes it's going to be a
501 c 3 charity uh and and
you're right sometimes people get uh
confused about that
we also have some things for some
political action committees that
that are maybe raising money on the web
um and people might also be
confused and saying hey maybe i can
deduct that well you can't
if it's if it's an advocacy organization
those donations are not tax deductible
it's it's charitable
some charitable organizations can do
advocacy they can't do political
campaign type stuff
so the and and so that's that's another
area where the public can get confused
very touchy issue yep yep great well
thank you tom i appreciate that
and uh uh unless anybody has any
particular questions for oh we do have a
couple questions
uh we'll start with you jane can you get
your hand up first before you
turn right yes so thank you mr chair
thank you tom for taking my question
um those calls that ask
um people for money for
police fund or fireman fund
do you know how much money actually goes
to
uh the police versus the people that
administer the calls
so if they're registered with us yes we
find out
and you'd be surprised to learn how
little goes
most of it goes to those fundraisers i
mean i i would
say often less than 50 percent goes to
those police and fire and what a point
in time you guys did a bad boy list you
had you
that you printed and and i did some of
them were
like ten percent yeah oh yeah sometimes
ninety percent goes to the fundraiser
and only ten percent of the chair so you
still
maintain that list or you still have i
haven't um so we have
yeah we have it we you know that's a
good idea maybe we ought to publicize
that again
that list off again and yeah especially
you know in giving
giving season so yeah and just to follow
up i just want to make a comment
um mr donovan's office i mean
they're so accessible and um he'll spend
as much time as he needs
with you if you have any questions
regarding non-profits or any of the
matters that he brought forward today
thanks tom
thank you next up is anita burroughs
representative burroughs you have a
question mr
chair and thank you tom for taking my
question um
you mentioned that you prefer to educate
them legislate
and you know i'm in a town we have a ton
of small nonprofits
by volunteers but very often the board
crosses over
and and takes over the executive
director's function
or the executive director is really
managing the board
at what what's this what's the tipping
point for you in terms of
taking action uh because i'm just seeing
this a lot and again i know it's
volunteers but i find it frustrating
that
they're not following you know they're
not following loss
so will um when we hear about these
situations we'll talk to board members
and saying
you know your role is to be uh
leadership in governed you're not there
to manage
or micromanage and um
we've done a little bit of what i'd call
marriage counseling um
between board members the board of
directors and
and the executive director is who's in
what lane etc
but that when the the
um executive director reports to the
board
uh the board hires and fires the
executive director it's the one
staff person that that they supervise
but but the board has to understand that
um if you don't like the executive
director maybe you can fire the person
but you got to let the executive
director do
his or her job thank you
and representative herbert has a
question
mr donovan how are you fine thanks
um would it be within the purview of the
legislature
to require that at least a minimum
amount of the money raised
go to i mean could we do that kind of
thing
or or should we even try
um i'm i would caution you states have
tried to do that
uh and they've been slapped down at
least three times by the u.s supreme
court
um and that happened back in the 1980s
and yes it was pretty common for states
to have these things and
the paid fundraiser community is
got great lawyers and
we're pretty much limited to
registration
and publication of of their fees that's
it should we do a 501c3
to fund uh taking it to the supreme
court again
not a serious question right we all we
all know uh
please put me on your do not call list
uh it should be
everybody's mantra um you know when when
you get these uh the associations i was
rather surprised i remember
when we put in this bill to regulate
this liz hager from concord actually was
the sponsor
and um and i remember when we were first
coming in and i was kind of
amazed of how the professionals and and
who do this and their poor and not
necessarily
um with our our fire police and whatever
so
please put me on your do not call list
all right well thank you very much tom
it was great
and last but not least we have brandon
from
the attorney general's office
representing the consumer protection
division
and uh good morning brandon good morning
mr chairman and
thank you ladies and gentlemen it's a
pleasure to be here in front of you to
talk about the work of the consumer
protection and antitrust bureau at the
department of justice
um my name is brandon grodd i am the
bureau chief of this bureau
we do a lot of different functions
um but all and i'll try to hit on each
of them as much as i can i know i have a
time limit
but the core of the work that we do in
the consumer protection antitrust bureau
to sum it up is those that are engaging
in trade or commerce within the state
you know those that
are selling goods selling services to
consumers
we insure and we ensure that they are
acting fairly
with consumers we ensure that they are
not deceiving consumers we ensure that
they are not
working to create unfair
um pricing or price fixing or
creating monopolies that would have an
adverse effect on competition
and on the consumers of the state of new
hampshire and we do that through a
variety of different functions
at the core of the work that we do is
new hampshire's consumer protection act
which is rsa 358a and
what the consumer protection act does is
it makes it illegal for those that are
engaged in trade traitor commerce in the
state of new hampshire
um to do a variety of different things
they're specifically listed in the
statute but
the type of conduct that's generally
prohibited is anything that is unfair
or deceptive and there are several
specific examples
of that such as conduct like offering
goods or
services and representing them as
something that they're not
representing them to be of a specific
quality when in fact that's not true
or representing them to be endorsed by a
specific organization when in fact
that's not true
things like that but then there's a
general prohibition against any unfair
deceptive
conduct in the process of engaging in
trade or commerce
in the state and so the way we enforce
that statute
is through a consumer protection hotline
that's open five days a week anybody in
the state can call in
call into our hotline and they can talk
to a real person it used to be
it used to be run 100 by volunteers uh
the pandemic has impacted that
gratefully i mean greatly um we do have
a couple still
but um we're much slower to respond than
we used to be it used to be that you
could call in and talk to somebody
instantly
now we have a little bit of a lag but we
do try to return all calls within 24
hours
anyone that thinks that they've been
wronged in trade or commerce in new
hampshire can call in
talk to a real person and an attorney in
this bureau will look at their problem
and determine whether it's something
that the consumer protection bureau has
the authority to take action on
we get about 7 500 calls and inquiries a
year
and that number seems to be growing
every year of that
we receive thousands of complaints every
year
that are actually amount to a potential
violation of new hampshire's consumer
protection act
for which we open an official complaint
matter
and we reach out to the business to try
to resolve this
and so because of the volume and the
limited resources that we have
you know we we receive a lot of stuff
where we serve
almost in a mediation type role you know
minor things for example you know if
a so somebody you know contracts to
build a house
and you know there's a disagreement on
you know the quality
of what was going to be used and the
consumer complains to us and we're able
to reach out to the person that built
the house
they're able to give their side of the
story to us and we're able to say well
you know is there a solution here that
can you know get both parties to a place
where they're comfortable and oftentimes
there is and we're able to do that just
through some communication
and through some strongly worded letters
from the attorney general's office that
tend to get the attention of businesses
in a way that
you know calls and emails from consumers
just can't
so we mediate a lot of these um and
quite successfully you know we recover
you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
consumers every year
just through that mediation process
sometimes the conduct that we see
and oftentimes is serious enough
that it's not something that simply
needs to be mediated it's something that
requires an enforcement action by this
office
and so the consumer protection act gives
to this bureau the ability to
bring civil enforcement actions against
a business that violates the consumer
protection act and a civil enforcement
action gives us the ability
to ask for a financial penalty of up to
ten thousand dollars per violation
also gives us the ability to ask the
court for
injunctive terms which would prevent the
business from acting in
a similar way in the future and in some
cases we're actually able to have the
court
close businesses down if they've
sufficiently violated the consumer
protection act we can impose
restrictions that prevent them from
continuing to do business
in the state of new hampshire we also
have the ability to bring
criminal violations of the consumer
protection act if we determine
that the conduct is egregious enough and
depending on whether we bring a charge
against an individual say there's one
bad actor in a business who violates the
consumer protection act
lying to consumers deceiving consumers
stealing from consumers
if it's against an individual it's a
misdemeanor level offense which means
they can go to jail for up to a year
we also have the ability to bring a
felony level consumer protection act
violation case against
the corporation or the entity itself
which carries with it
a penalty of up to a hundred thousand
dollar fine which is a very significant
remedy
for most businesses so we
receive these complaints we evaluate
them we have attorneys
investigators who are sworn law
enforcement officers
we have a financial analyst that's able
to look through and
you know document intensive cases that's
able to you know analyze documents in
order to give us a better picture of
what's going on
we have a team of dedicated paralegals
and support staff
and through this process we regularly
bring both
civil and criminal enforcement actions
for violations of new hampshire's
consumer protection act
and you know this has become more
important i think this year than ever
before i think the work of the bureau is
always important but the pandemic has
really given
wave to a whole new world of consumer
protection
violations that we weren't seeing before
uh and some of them are you know just
starting to happen right now you know as
we move
towards a vaccine in the promise of you
know a vaccine being available to
different people at different periods of
times it's really it's created
an opportunity for people to really take
advantage of that situation and
it leads to what i'll explain to you is
a classic violation of
a classic example of unfair and
deceptive conduct so what we're seeing
is
people posting advertisements people
making representations
people sending out mailers that are
advertising the ability to pay money to
reserve your spot to get a vaccine
or to pay money to you know cut the line
to get a vaccine
we also see people that are advertising
products
often nutrients supplements various
different things that they advertise as
being able to prevent covid
or to treat covid um those types of
representations
um are simply false and you know it's
those types of representations
saying to a consumer in commerce i can
sell you this product
it will have this effect when in reality
the person selling the product has no
reasonable basis to to make that
statement
or they create a representation that
they have the ability to administer a
vaccine when in fact
there's no ability to buy your way to a
vaccine there's no ability to save your
spot in line
um and so through those sorts of
fraudulent conduct we do see people that
are trying to take advantage
of the pandemic and i think i'd like to
think that we've made a big difference
in protecting
consumers from falling victim to those
types of scams
and frauds throughout the course of the
pandemic
so there it does come with some um
exemptions we're not able to look at
everything and the exemptions
of certain conduct is specifically
exempt from the consumer protection act
if it is the type of conduct that is
regulated by
certain other state agencies those being
the
bureau of uh the department of insurance
the department of banking
the bureau of securities regulation who
we just heard from and the public
utilities commission so if
if actors are engaging in unfair
deceptive acts or practices
and it's uh let's say a mortgaging
company that's regulated by the banking
department
the banking department has its own
unfair deceptive acts or practices
statute
we wouldn't be able to take action on
that that's something the banking
department would have to do
in addition to 358a the consumer
protection act
we also enforce rsa 356 which
we call the antitrust act what it
prohibits
is monopolies combinations
price fixing those types of transactions
that
work to lessen competition and lessen
consumer
choice in the state of new hampshire and
a great example of this
as you know attorney donovan said during
his presentation
the charitable trust division looks at
hospital combinations for certain
certain reasons that he articulated the
antitrust division of the consumer
protection bureau
looks at them to determine whether or
not they violate 356
which like the consumer protection act
has both civil and criminal penalties so
it's it's a law enforcement statute
that if two entities like as you're
aware you know hospitals are the
the hot ticket combination in the state
right now if two entities try to merge
together
we review that transaction to determine
whether if successful and
if completed in the form that's
currently proposed
that transaction will have the effect of
reducing competition and reducing
consumer choice in new hampshire
and if it does we have the ability to
file a suit essentially asking the court
to block that transaction
prevent it from happening also we see
this less
now really what the antitrust work
that's focused on right now is these
mergers and combinations but
we would also have the ability to look
at
price fixing schemes agreements between
different companies that they're going
to set their prices
sufficiently high so that it while it
appears consumers actually have choice
and there's an open market what they're
doing is gradually driving prices up
without consumers even knowing it based
on agreements between
two or more businesses so that they can
each profit in turn
we currently are prosecuting along with
almost every other state in the country
several suits against various generic
prescription drug manufacturing
companies in the country throughout the
country
that were doing just this were basically
working with each other to make sure
that the cost of prescription drugs
for each of their companies was as high
as possible and eliminating the ability
for a free market to
allow the better product to to be the
higher product and
consumers to choose you know between a
generic product and a brand name product
that choice was essentially eliminated
based on the lawsuits that we've brought
um and so that's a really good example
of you know price fixing
and how our bureau in conjunction with
all the other attorney general's office
in this
state can review and bring a
prosecutorial action if people violate
the um antitrust statute and so the
the context of working with other states
is also very important
you know i've talked about you know how
we would bring
consumer protection act or antitrust
violations on an individual basis you
know new hampshire ver the state of new
hampshire versus an individual
there's also much much bigger consumer
protection
work being done throughout the country
where all of or the majority of state's
attorneys general's offices
will pool together to take on bigger
companies
we've recently filed lawsuits against
google
lawsuits against facebook these are
efforts where
all the resources of the ag's office
throughout the country have
pooled together their resources from
their consumer protection division in
order to look at the practices of
companies
that you know are so big that no
individual state would be able to to
look at them on their own and
become a force to be reckoned with to
try to protect not only new hampshire's
consumers but consumers throughout the
country
from both consumer protection and
antitrust violations
so a few other of the the functions that
this bureau undertakes
um we have a tobacco enforcement
division i won't get into the the nitty
gritty of this
but the the long and short of it is that
based on a settlement agreement with the
major tobacco companies many many years
ago
the state receives a substantial amount
of money every year from tobacco
companies
we work to enforce their participation
in their obligations to
provide money to the states that's
supposed to be used to mitigate the
impact that
smoking and tobacco products has had um
on the public in general in all
states that join this agreement so we
are
working with various different
manufacturers of tobacco products
throughout the country
to protect and make sure that new
hampshire receives the compensation that
is due
under this agreement which is i believe
is over 40 million dollars last year
and you know is around that much every
year
that's our tobacco enforcement unit
there's an elder abuse and financial
exploitation unit
which is something i'm very proud of
that was the position that i held before
i took the role
of bureau chief here it's a purely
criminal unit
that is 100 dedicated to the
investigation
and prosecution of those who take
advantage of the elderly in the state of
new hampshire
and jeff spill from the bureau of
securities regulation i heard him talk
briefly about
um some of the conduct that is
investigated
and scams is a big part of it but some
of the other work that we do
in really the majority of the work that
we do in the elder exploitation world is
people that are put in a position of
trust a fiduciary capacity like a
trustee
a guardian or a power of attorney for an
elderly person
and violate that trust in order to take
advantage and steal from an elderly
person deprive them of their
life savings we take those cases very
very seriously and there are numerous
people that are
currently incarcerated at the state
prison just for doing exactly that
so we have one attorney and one victim
advocate that are entirely dedicated to
that work
and so the consumer protection act also
as you'll see in legislation that will
inevitably come forward this year
it also links up with various other
statutes
all throughout the new hampshire rsas
and
specifically makes violation of various
different statutes
a violation of the consumer protection
act if it's consumer related
a great example of this is the bureau is
responsible
for registering and regulating all the
health clubs and all the martial arts
studios in the state of new hampshire
the reason that it's necessary for
consumer protection in this area is
health clubs and martial arts studios
operate on a model where people pay in
advance for their services
so you can purchase you know a year of a
gym membership up front
or a year's worth of personal training
classes up front
but what happens if the gym then
disappears six months
six months into that you know contract
uh
we make sure that gyms that are offering
prepaid services martial arts studios
that are offering prepaid services
they have to register with us they have
to disclose their prepaid liability to
us
and we make sure that they have a bond
in place that covers their refund
liability in the event
that the school closes we have the
ability to
draw on that bond in order to get
consumers their money back
there's also various other things that
they have to disclose to us for the
purpose of consumer protection
various requirements in their contract
to make sure that they're fully
disclosing to members
you know all of their responsibilities
make sure that they're not taking
advantage of people
we regulate all the health clubs in the
state and if they fail to register with
us it ties back and it's a it's a
violation of the consumer protection act
so we would have the ability to bring
all of those same remedies and penalties
that i discussed earlier either symbol
civilly or criminally depending on how
serious the violation is
you know i've so i've worked very
quickly through you know the world of
the types of stuff that we cover
uh just give you a few examples of the
types of consumer protection work that
we generally see in this bureau
just to bring it home and then i'm happy
to take questions you know
far and away the the top complaints
that we get through our hotline process
and through our complaint process
are car dealerships and contractors
cardio especially used car dealerships
creates
enormous potential for the violation of
consumer protection laws specifically in
representing used cars to be of a
specific
condition or quality when in fact that's
not true you know when you go and you
buy a new
used car you're really dependent to a
large extent on the dealership being
honest with you
and disclosing you know has it been in
prior accidents what sort of condition
is it in
how many miles does it have all those
things need to be
clearly and plainly disclosed and
concealing that information from a
consumer lying to a consumer about the
condition of a car you know it's it's
advertised as
runs gray will pass inspection consumer
drives it off a lot and you know the
thing breaks down on the way home and
turns out it's nowhere near passing an
inspection
and nobody's looked at the things so the
dealership's saying you know
runs great will pass inspection unless
they've actually inspected it they've
actually looked at it and they can back
up that representation
that would be a violation of new
hampshire's consumer protection act as
an unfair
deceptive statement that was made to the
consumer
contractors are i think it's probably 50
50. i think we get just as many used car
complaints as we get contractor
complaints
and you know contractors in new
hampshire don't need to be licensed
they're not regulated in any capacity
other than through the consumer
protection bureau and it just creates
the potential for an enormous amount of
taking money up front either to buy
materials or prepayments for labor
to to do some sort of a construction job
and then
the person disappears with the money and
the consumer never sees them again
and you know we have to toe the line
between
you we cannot get involved in contract
disputes
so a contract dispute specifically by
law
is does not rise to the level of a
consumer protection act violation there
has to be something more
there has to be something more egregious
about the conduct that would make it
um something that the attorney general's
office would enforce versus you know
something that the parties would
litigate between themselves in small
claims court or
in a civil court um so we get a lot of
complaints about quality of work you
know somebody you know builds a deck
and then they a year later they're
having all sorts of problems with the
deck
because the contractor did subpar work
you know
that's potentially a you know a contract
dispute the person didn't do the work to
the level
that you know they were supposed to do a
consumer can take that individual to
court
you have a situation where a person pays
money for say ten thousand dollars for
the deck
the same deck you know so the person can
go out and buy materials
and then the person never shows up never
provides a consumer with any materials
never gives them any of their money back
that's a situation that we see all the
time and that is where we can be really
effective
because we are able to not only bring
consumer protection act violations but
we also have general
criminal jurisdiction in this bureau and
can bring
felony theft charges as well as consumer
protection act violations against those
individuals
and we're able to get court-ordered
restitution as well as significant
punitive sanctions such as
jail time or fines if appropriate for
contractors that are engaged in those
sorts of unfair deceptive acts or
practices
so i feel like i've spoken for a very
long time that's a very very high level
view of the work the bureau does
i'm very happy to take any specific
questions at this point if they're
already
well that was excellent brandon you
really did cover all the
all the nooks and crannies and i really
appreciate you
making that presentation so we do have a
couple of questions we'll start with
representative patoozik uh good morning
sir
my question is on
generic drugs now i've had an issue
i used to take a prescription medication
uh which went generic
and then uh because well myelin and tiva
are the two
worst uh generic drug manufacturers
that a they raise the price
because there is only one generic
manufacturer
and they control what it is
uh is there any definition
for a generic drug anywhere in
the new hampshire uh regulations
so i'm not sure i understand your
question is is there a definition
for a generic drug a generic drug by
definition
is a non-name so when you create a drug
you know you invent a new drug the
company that makes it
has a certain period of exclusivity
where they're the only ones that get to
sell the drug because they came up with
the formula
so they're given an opportunity to
profit off their ingenuity
for a certain period of time and once
that period of time lapses
other companies can start make using
their formula to create what's called
generic versions of that drug
so it's any drug that is made that is
not a name brand drug
would be a generic drug but i'm not sure
if that's the question you're asking me
okay part of the part of the question is
uh
when when it goes generic there might be
one
manufacturer uh in my case it's myelin
yeah so so hey john um the simple
answer is just like any any anybody who
has a patent
when you lose your patent it's free for
anybody to make it it doesn't mean that
anybody else is going to make it
or copy it it just means that they're
free to do it so
so in terms of the where i don't know
where you're going with this maybe you
can
we can talk offline on this one but uh
but
in general um you know the generic
in when when people think about
pharmaceutical is pretty much
just think in terms of patents when
you're running your when your patent
runs out
anybody can copy what you did anybody
could produce the product
whether they do it or not is another
subject
okay and mylan are subject to
one of the the current pending
multi-state suits that has been brought
by this office and attorney general's
offices throughout the country
thank you that would be under the
monopoly there were there was more of
the terms of the monopoly
issue right in this price fixing yeah
price fixing exactly
okay uh representative herbert is up
next
thank you uh mr chairman um
nice uh presentation i i was interested
uh
it was interesting but i uh two
questions
if i may um number one is
contractor disputes
or you know frauds or whatever if you're
a plumber you have to get a license
if you're an electrician you have to get
a license
i would assume that most contractors
hire licensed professionals
maybe some don't and then you get some
quality issues
is there any uh is there
would it be a good idea to have a
general contractor's license or is there
some way of
of so doing so as to best ensure
uh getting a quality job i mean
somebody's always gonna
buy the cheapest stuff there and get
exactly what they paid for but there is
no license is there or
is there is no new hampshire does not
have any licensing requirement for
contractors
so is that unusual anybody can become a
contractor
simply by declaring themselves a
contractor so representative herbert you
are getting into
policy here and uh so it's a little
awkward to ask
the department about a policy uh this
policy issue
of licensure contractors has been in
front of the commerce committee in the
past
it's been a while since we've had it um
but it has been in the past
um and uh and in every time it it did
not pass
um and i'll and i'll love to talk to you
offline
about uh why why it didn't pass
but because i i was in the room when it
happened so okay
but i would say that it is a policy
issue so it's awkward to ask him
okay so second question i don't think is
a policy issue maybe it is but uh
and that is a real simple one um
you ran across a lot of responsibilities
there
do you have a manpower problem
or could you use could you use another
attorney or two right that's
just a uh i know it's it's touchy
because we live in a you know an
environment where it's very difficult to
raise money
uh at times and so that's an issue
but i'm i'm concerned also with the
ability to provide the service
at a level that i think my citizens my
constituents deserve
and if you're short a man or two or a
woman or two or
uh i would be i would be interested in
knowing
about that let me answer it this way
um we are limited to the work we can do
by the resources that we have and we
have
um at this point we have three lawyers
that
including myself that do the general
consumer protection work we have one
full-time and one part-time lawyer
that do all of the state's antitrust
work
we have one lawyer doing tobacco we have
one lawyer doing elder abuse
we could without question be doing a lot
more if we had additional resources
just one minor technical thing is this
something that we would hear from
the attorney general himself
in other words if it's requested by him
uh that's probably a better he has a
better chance of uh
getting that help than if uh brandon
garad is uh even though he's being
very honest i can't wait for the a.g to
show up
every budget cycle we go through uh the
ag's office will
always have no to the finance committee
that they could use use more help and i
would say
that i pretty much that's in my annual
event that does occur
and then the ag is the one who does
request and then it is part of the
of their their budget um i look forward
to helping him
and for us it's actually kind of unusual
because different from all the other
uh departments that we regulate which
are self-funded
this is the only one that really is not
self-funded
however i would say that um they've been
doing a wonderful job
with some of these class you know not
national lawsuits and have been bringing
in
more revenue than ever before um but we
wouldn't call it a revenue we've called
it
fines or assessment but but that um you
know they are they're doing better
and it's been it's been positive but um
it is true that
that unlike some say so like for
instance vermont the banking in
an insurance department is uh is not uh
assessment run it is actually part of
the general fund
but so having said that uh thank you
very much brandon it was great
and i didn't do it i don't see any more
hands oh representative
milo has has one more question yeah
um uh rental property owners um do you
have oversight
on um uh conditions
of a property that's being rented by an
individual
so it depends you know we so this is
this ties back to the definition of
trade or commerce
the consumer protection act applies to
those that are engaged in trade or
commerce in new hampshire
so you know and to use an example here
to answer your question
if you have a landlord whose business it
is is being a landlord
you know owns several properties makes
his living off being a landlord
and is in any way acting in an unfair or
deceptive manner in the course of that
business of renting properties
yes we would have the ability to
investigate and potentially bring
an enforcement action if it's you know
an individual
that has a guest house and rents their
guest house out
you know just to make a little side
money that's probably not considered
trader commerce
and that's something that would have to
be litigated you know individually by
the parties
but we do get complaints against the
landlords routinely we look at them
i mean unfortunately the most common
complaint we get is disputes about
security deposits
and that's not something that we can get
involved and you know that's very
specifically you know
there's an agreement where you know a
person collects a security deposit it
will be returned if certain conditions
are met
and you know there's a disagreement
about whether those conditions were met
or not
that's a classic example of you know
really what they're debating
is the contract and who violated the
contract and who didn't
you know that's something that would
have to be resolved civilly but for
example if a landlord
who was engaged in trade or commerce
posted an advertisement
that represented that his apartments
were of a sufficient quality
um or that had they had certain
amenities that allured
uh lured people into signing lease
agreements when in fact that was a lie
you know they were actually of a lesser
quality or they didn't have the
amenities as advertised those would be
consumer protection act violations that
we could get involved in
great thank you very much so yeah like
any department there but they can't
talk about any specific cases that are
going on
but when you take what's happening in
peterborough right now because
near and dear that time two times over
for me and range
that you mean clearly if you're the
landlord's pointing out that these are
legitimate properties that you can rent
you know and he's making that promise
and then not follow through
um clearly that that is a potential
consumer protection violation
the only other thing i would want to
mention just so everybody get
has it in your head is that the consumer
protection is about uh
individuals so um a uh
generally a corporation you know a
corporate agreement
suing another corporation that's that's
we don't
get involved in that even carry over to
some banking insurance
that we don't really we we don't in
terms of our consumer protections and
their statutes and their
which they you know to the right of
restitution that those departments have
is it really is about harming a conv an
individual
if a corporation has a contractual
problem they got to
take that up separately but that would
not involve our department and agencies
involved in that so uh thank you very
much brandon this was great
and appreciated and uh so now
being 11 25 so now i'm going to ask um
all the uh lobbyists who would like to
introduce themselves
to go ahead raise your hands and
um and then we'll we'll go through this
list
i see there's already 24 attendees so
this could be
reactive um i would say please don't uh
spend too long just uh introduce
yourself
and uh you know talk about the you know
who you're
who your employer is and what your
issues are but be remember it's uh
it's between what it was the famous line
that you are now between us and our
lunch
so uh please be model of brevity okay so
the this list uh i thought it was gonna
be alphabetical so i guess it was
whoever could click it the fastest
which turns out to be henry veyu so i'm
going to promote you to a panelist henry
and you can then just unmute yourself
and go ahead and speak
perfect hi great uh thank you
um good uh good morning everyone it's
still morning um
my name is henry value i'm with the
lobbying firm
of she infinity capital group um we
our firm represents a variety of clients
the clients that uh you'll see me
before your committee include
the new hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
and where they're typically for liquor
issues
menu labeling those kinds of things
we i also represent the american council
of life insurers
and they've got life insurance products
annuities uh long-term care insurance
uh disability uh insurance products
uh so obviously with the insurance
aspect of your committee i'm i'm
here before uh those issues um
i also represent the entertainment
software association
they are an association of video game
manufacturers
an issue that's come up over the past
several years
is the right to repair and i believe
there's a another bill in this session
we also represent the hospital
corporation of america
that's portsmouth hospital parkman
hospital
and frisbee hospital they are the only
for-profit hospital in the state of new
hampshire
issues that come before your committee
that
that impact them deal with things like
hospital mergers
and the the attorney general's review of
those kinds of
mergers also represent
uh lkq they are
an after markets auto part uh
manufacturer and uh there's often
uh auto parts legislation that comes
before
the committee so those are the clients
that
you'll see me come before your committee
on and it was uh thank you very much for
the opportunity to introduce myself
okay great thank you henry all right
next up is glenn
perlow
all right you're you're in you just have
to unmute yourself glenn
i have done so uh thanks so much uh
chairman hunt
um nice to see the returning members of
the committee and welcome to new members
of the committee
uh my name is glenn perlow i am vice
president and chief compliance officer
at jordan park trust company in hampton
uh those who have seen me testify before
will know
we were a prospecta trust company and we
were recently acquired
by a larger uh investment advisor out of
san francisco in new york
um which i hope is reflective of the
success
of what we've been at since uh
well since uh chairman hunt uh has
worked on
trust modernization and our efforts to
build it so they will come
uh i just want to mention uh briefly
i'm also president of new hampshire
trust council if i didn't say that
um and uh in the past we've been known
for epically long legislation
and um as uh commissioner little
mentioned yesterday
uh there is reason not to do that this
term
especially but also um i'm trying to
reflect
on that and present the committee with
more manageable bites
so i will just briefly mention uh
lsr2021-0760 which i don't think has
come out in bill language yet um is
blissfully two pages long
we hope and thank non-controversial uh
and i very much look forward to
um to uh working with the committee and
uh telling you more about
uh our industry thanks very much all
right thank you glenn
uh next up is kate frye
okay kate you're on just uh
don't forget to unmute yourself
hello sorry uh i got
kicked off just as i was uh you called
my name so
huh my name is kate fry
i'm with a new futures which is a
non-profit nonpartisan
organization work that works on health
and wellness issues our
areas of policy that we work on include
substance use disorder health care
access to treatment
early childhood and children's
behavioral health
my role as a lobbyist my bucket area
really includes alcohol and other drugs
so you will see me a lot with
uh liquor bills and we work closely with
um the commission and other partners i
have a colleague on the phone
uh as well too who will introduce
yourself herself uh who works on health
care issues and thank you and i hope you
have a
very good year unique year this ahead of
us this year good to see you all
good to see you thank you okay next up
is ellen scarpony
so ellen yeah ellen all you have to do
is
uh you've been promoted all you have to
do is
unmute yourself
here i am i hope great yes
hi hi there good morning
uh almost afternoon it's good to
actually
see all of you i'm ellen scarpone and i
represent consolidated communications
we are the phoenix that rose from the
old new england telephone
9x verizon fairpoint and now we are
consolidated
we provide telephone broadband and
business communications
uh with over 46 000 fiber route miles
in 23 states in new hampshire
specifically we provide
service to over 244 communities
of note and things that we will bring be
before your committee for
is that since the passage of the
municipal bonding
broadband bonding legislation which is
rsa 33
3g as well as the cares act grants we're
working to partner
with over 15 municipalities right now to
expand and build
high-speed fiber broadband networks
including
the rural communities of rindge
mr chairman uh chesterfield dublin
danbury
mason errol springfield and a host of
others
i've been in telecom for over 40 years
during my career i've also owned and
operated a theatrical resort in maine
was briefly with merrill lynch in
burlington vermont
was with east atlantic advertising in
manchester and owned a dream dinner
meal prep franchise in bedford and the
reason i tell you that
is that i do have a a varied background
please please let me know if you have
any questions about what we do at
consolidated
and or if you have any constituent
concerns i live in canterbury and i look
forward to working with all of you
thanks great thank you
okay next we have susan paschall
oops uh all right i'm promoting you now
susan
and just remember to unmute yourself
good morning thanks thanks um
mr chairman and members of the committee
i think i'm unmuted
yes you are you're on sorry i should be
here
there you are video on too yup
hi i work at the dupont group um
there are several of us who you'll see
in your committee this session
uh jim monahan kate horgan tristan craig
myself and we represent a number of
health care um
organizations we work with new futures
with cape frye
we work with a number of substance use
disorder and treatment
recovery providers we work with solution
health which is the parent
system for elliot hospital and southern
new hampshire
medical center the largest health care
system in the state we work with the 10
10 community mental health centers we
work with bi-state
primary care which is the community
health centers and the fqhcs
the new hampshire nurse practitioners
the new hampshire dental
hygienist association the county nursing
homes
and then on the technology side we work
with deloitte and
apple so um welcome back
returning members and i'll i'm looking
forward to meeting on new members
as well thank you great thank you
all right next is going to be holly
stevens
[Music]
and i'm promoting you holly
and just don't forget to unmute yourself
hello oh i've got a nice halo in the
back um
thank you chairman hunt for uh giving us
this opportunity to introduce ourselves
to
members of uh the commerce committee um
holly stevens i work with kate fry at
new futures
um i'm gonna spare you the uh giving you
the description of uh what new futures
is and does again
um but as kate mentioned i do the health
policy
um aspect when i originally took the
position at new features
i thought i was going to be downstairs
in health and human services
most of the time and as luck would have
it i actually find myself upstairs in
commerce
probably about 90 percent of the time
that
i'm over at the house
mainly because i'm working on a lot of
health insurance issues and other health
issues that come before
your committee unlike a lot of the other
lobbyists
kate and i don't really have any clients
per se
we are funded to work on behalf
of the the residents of the state of new
hampshire
so we are more than happy to provide any
and all
information um that you may need um you
can
reach out to us um
via email and or phone um
and it's nice to see the returning
numbers and
i like many others i'm looking forward
to uh meeting
the new members on the committee as well
and thank you again chairman on
okay thank you uh next
is jody grimlis
and i'm promoting you jody and don't
forget to
unmute yourself
can you hear me now yes we can okay
um hi mr chairman members of the
committee it's good to see
all of you i don't actually think i can
start my video too there we go there we
go
um it is good to see all of you and
welcome to the new members of the
committee
um i'm part of a small firm
my firm is myself and my colleague adam
schmidt
we've been representing clients at the
state house for both of us now over
20 years or so we represent a wide
variety of clients
we have some of the clients you may see
us in front of your community for
we have the new hampshire association of
realtors we work with the
insurance and financial advisor
um we work with cvs health um so if you
have questions or
information needed from cvs please let
us know the new hampshire beverage
association which are the non-alcoholic
um the coca-colas and the pepsi
providers here in the state
um as well as others so we see ourselves
as facilitators we want to provide you
the information you need
um facts research data whatever we can
do we're just here to be a resource and
look forward to working with you all
i will follow up with that um an email
introduction with that list all of our
clients so that way
um you have our contact information a
little bit about us and um
ways to get in touch with us if you need
so again thank you all it's good to see
you all i can't wait till we get to all
see each other in person again
and look forward to working with you and
nice seeing you too jody okay next up
is nancy vaughn and i'm promoting you
nancy
and just don't forget to
you're there yes good good morning still
sorry i also looked like i was being
thrown off for a moment there but
um so thank you very much chairman hunt
members of the commerce committee for
this opportunity to introduce myself
again i'm nancy vaughn
i am government relations director for
the american heart association
which i am a full-time staff member for
and in addition to funding research and
creating educational materials for
individuals to prevent and
treat heart disease and stroke we also
do advocate
for public policies really focused
mostly on patients and individuals that
we want to have avoid
developing risk factors which lead to
heart disease and stroke
the what we really do what we basically
do is
with with the research that's out there
we create evidence-based
public policies um and we
will come before you should there be
policies in front of you
regarding issues like um access to
health care
access to health insurance also the the
quality affordability of
of all of that care we also
will come before you if tobacco issues
mainly regarding
retailers i believe but also that are
really about consumer protections our
main concern around tobacco control is
really making sure that
young people youth and young adults
don't get started
with using tobacco products and again i
want to be a resource to this committee
so if there are any issues that you're
interested in learning more about
regarding heart disease and stroke
i hope that you'll consider me a
resource to you and
i look forward to this coming session
and hope things go smoothly for all of
you
and again thank you very much thank you
uh and coincidentally another
related industry mike rolo another
former state rep who uh
you're ready to go mike
sorry i got bounce ac like everyone else
it looks like i'm getting bounced out
but i'm here
so thank you mr chairman i hope i'm
guessing you can hear me looking at your
facial expressions
i can hear you anyways i'm mike rolo i'm
the
government relations director for the
american cancer society cancer action
network
which is a mouthful so we usually just
say acs can
we are the non-profit nonpartisan
advocacy affiliate of the american
cancer society
that supports evidence-based uh
policy and legislative solutions
designed to eliminate
um cancer as a major health burden in
this country
and i'm looking forward to um working
with all of you and seeing you although
i don't think my picture's not coming up
so
i put a tie on for nothing mr chairman
you can't join me
oh well oh well but thank you very much
for the opportunity i'm looking forward
to
seeing you all right okay uh
next up is katie cole
my phone i put it on mute why the muting
is not working
oh hang up on him okay go ahead okay
i guess this we're bumping people off
unfortunately and i don't have to
um why that's happening hi mr chairman
can you hear me
yes we can yes hi okay sorry about that
my name is katie cole
and i am the public policy manager for
the freedom health plan
um that was recently acquired by united
health group
um we have about 40 000 members in new
hampshire
and you primarily will see me working on
issues related to health care and health
insurance and
issues facing the small group market um
i'll keep it short and sweet for today
but i'm looking forward to working
hello working with all of you this
session albeit remotely
and it's good to see everybody great
well thank you
and also on the health insurance route
i'm now
heidi crowe
and so we'll see heidi
she'll get bumped off and you gotta turn
it back on
can you hear me mr chairman yes i can
okay great thank you
um good morning everyone um it's nice to
see all of you
um familiar faces as well as folks who
are new to the committee
uh my name is heidi kroll i work at
gallagher callahan and gartrell
and um i represent america's health
insurance plans
are otherwise known as ahip which is the
national trade association for the
health insurance carriers
here in new hampshire our members
include
anthem harvard pilgrim cigna
and the three medicaid care
organizations as well hopefully i
haven't forgotten anybody
um at any rate we uh i work
you know closely with with your
committee on a variety of
health insurance bills and health care
bills that come before you
um as other folks have said
would certainly welcome the opportunity
to give you
any information you may need i always
want to be a resource
for you and
you know just look forward to working
with you and
i know you're going to be working
remotely initially but hopefully we get
back in person at some time
soon but feel free to call me or email
me at any time if i don't have answers
for you
right away i will certainly work to get
them
to get you answers as quickly as
possible so thank you very much
thank you all right next is gina
powers and i'm promoting you gina
so you're now in the panelist list
oh there we go sorry about that there
you go perfect
hi everyone i'm gina powers with wrath
young and pignatelli
um here in concord or not here i'm
non-concord in concord new hampshire
um we represent a whole multitude of
clients
um and we'll be coming before you
uh for several different of them several
different industries
american express anthem insurance amazon
comcast credit unions the new hampshire
grocers association
the united states travel insurance
association and
reynolds american i work with four other
gentlemen who you'll see
periodically dave collins rich parsons
kyle baker
and bobby collins no no relation
and um i look forward to working with
all of you
and please use us as a resource uh email
us or call us and we'll be happy to get
you
any information that you might need
great thank you gina
uh next up is curtis berry
okay
um good morning
there you are great good morning chris
thank you for the opportunity
um i am curtis barry uh and wanted to
introduce a few of the clients that i
represent before the committee on a
regular basis um
starting with a pcma it's a trade
association of the
pharmacy benefit management association
um
pharmacy benefit managers are often
misunderstood in their role in
uh reimbursement for the prescription
drugs uh happy to provide
information and a briefing on that at
the the committee's
uh discretion uh convenience also the
new hampshire optometric association
which represents over 170 doctors of
optometry
whoops i healthcare in the state the new
hampshire retail association which
represents
retailers of all shapes and sizes
including many of the nationally based
retailers who operate in the state
but over 90 percent of their membership
includes new hampshire based
main street type stores and and they're
interested in a wide variety of interest
uh issues that come before the committee
the new hampshire retail lumber
association which is
our building material suppliers
throughout the state
independently owned many of them the
cigar association of new hampshire which
is a coalition of premium
retail cigar shops hope to have a
hearing very early on on
a bill that they have interest in coming
before the committee
and then lastly microsoft corporation
occasionally has some interest in policy
matters
uh that and i uh occasionally present
the microsoft point of view on
on some of those issues uh hopefully you
received an email from me last week
with a little bit more detail on on a
lot of these and my contact information
and
looking forward to uh getting to work
thank you mr dinner
all right thank you curtis good job all
right next up
is ryan hill and i'm promoting you now
ryan
and my understanding is you
i don't know you're getting thrown out
or you're now a panelist so
i am here can you hear me yo look at
look at that fancy background oh
you know trying to impress
well welcome everyone it's great to see
uh returning members and welcome um
to the new members of the committee it's
uh it's great to
virtually see everyone i look forward to
the day where we can
be doing this in person again um to just
give you a quick background this is i
think my ninth session
on lobbying um i've spent the last three
years with the bankers association prior
to that
i was with the automobile dealers
association
so between the two have spent a lot of
time in front of this committee
um as the commissioner little said
yesterday many of the banking bills uh
come before this committee
um what you'll see is banking is a very
uh complex uh industry it's a
heavily regulated and for the most part
we try to maintain a level playing field
between
the um this state uh
state laws and federal laws um and
really maintaining uh what's on this
parity
um i sent the committee just uh some
background earlier this morning
um please feel free to reach out uh it
does include my contact information
as well as christie merrill president of
our
association who may be on the call right
now
and uh if she is i think she has some
uh comments she'd like to make but uh it
gives a little bit of a background
of banking um how it's regulated our
priority issues
and i think really important right now
is how the industry has responded to
covet helping their communities
get through this very difficult economic
time
i i would be happy at any point if any
of
especially the new members and existing
members if
anyone's interested um in scheduling a
time to meet to really do a deeper dive
into
the industry um and how it's regulated
at the state and federal level
um and again i look forward to the day
where we get to do this in person and
get to meet
in person all the new members um and uh
that's all i have for now
thank you report good job all right next
up
is scott shire i'm
promoting the owl scott
and while i'm promoting you has got
representative terry wants to know why
he can't get
ling ling beer
so not that you have to okay
answer that question great question
excuse me actually that is a very
specific question with res very
with respect to a particular brand
but it goes to it goes to the broader
question as a new representative
of how it is determined that
a producer can obtain permission to
market in the state of new hampshire
so thank you yeah well let me let me
address that real quickly and we can
always have an offline discussion later
but basically
um it's the decision of the supplier or
in this case the brewer
to come to the state whether they want
to they would have to get
the appropriate license to bring their
product into the state and then as
um chairman malika alluded to earlier to
go through the three-tier system they
would work with
a wholesaler partner in the middle tier
and then bring it to retail
obviously in the last few years as you
know they've chosen to to move into
the state south of our border the great
state of massachusetts
but they have not decided to come here
for a variety of reasons
which i do not know specifically what
those reasons are but
i know we do get a lot of requests like
that for particular products people have
a great uh deal of pride of origin um as
somebody who's spent
several years of my life living in
philadelphia i come to appreciate
yingling as well
and every once in a while i will go
across the border and grab some and
bring it home so
um but happy to happy to chat about um
those specific circumstances or beer in
general later but
before i do that um good morning
i know that lunch is coming up thank you
chairman hunt
and congratulations to all the members
of the committee on your election
and assignment to this dynamic committee
and thanks for allowing me to introduce
myself today
i'm scott shire i've worked in the beer
industry for the last 18 years in a
variety of roles at both brewers and
distributors
and i've been here in new hampshire for
about eight years
and prior to that i worked in a variety
of commercial development roles for a
large brewer down in latin america
but since coming back here to new
hampshire with my family i've been the
director
of the new hampshire beer distributors
association i'm
an employee of that association and i
registered to lobby on
on their behalf and do a variety of
commercial and economic development
uh matters for them as well as industry
affairs working with our brewer
and retailer partners both in the on and
the off premise
as well as government relations so i'm
at your service to provide any feedback
or consult with you on any beverage
alcohol policy
that might come up to talk about any
consumer issues or commercial matters
with regard to constituents either
and um can you hear me okay yeah you're
just a little little burp there i am
i've got uh
home should crappy uh internet at home
like many people in new hampshire so
i'm looking forward to broadband
expansion too anyway
um i live in durham uh new hampshire
right now with my wife and
and two kids in school and and serve on
a variety of non-profit boards
in the state like new hampshire the
beautiful new hampshire community
seafood and brew new hampshire
and i'm looking forward to working with
you as needed
and thanks again for your time today
that's all i've got great
thank you scott that was great thanks uh
representative terry you can always uh
use the direct shipping law
my direct shipping law you can have beer
delivered to your house
otherwise yes you'll have to venture
south
okay next is paula manahan from the
hospital association
good morning paula
good morning everyone sorry about that
hopefully you can hear me
um and welcome back to
um all the members and welcome to the
new members that have joined um
this like someone said a very dynamic
committee it's a it's a great committee
and um
the hospital association is
comes in front of the committee quite
often and primarily
focused on health insurance um health
care
issues um so we are there quite often
um my colleague nick corona actually
um is on as well and hopefully he will
get asked to just introduce himself real
quick
he is actually more present um in your
committee than i
because i spend time in other committees
as well
i am the um the senior vice president of
state government relations for the
hospital association
and have been here almost 19 or have
been here 19 years
and we want to be a resource for you i
encourage our member our hospital
members who are all
all the hospitals in new hampshire are
part of the hospital association
they do as henry said and others they
have individual
lobbyists sometimes but we we lobby for
all of them
and we encourage our hospitals to reach
out to the legislators and i know a lot
of you have attended
legislative breakfast in the past this
year
i think they will be done virtually and
we will be working with our members to
make sure that they do
hopefully set that up but in the
meantime we are a resource and again you
will see nick at some point he will um
get called on so you can at least see
his nice face
um and then um you can also reach out to
us
at any time if you have any questions
about
our hospitals so thank you and i look
forward to getting to work
great thank you paula next is dan
bennett
from the auto dealers
all right dan you're on
hopefully you're on
oh you're there yes are you there mr
chairman oh there you go good oh look
you've got a fancy background too
okay all right uh good morning and uh
thank you for the opportunity
congratulations to all of you on your
selection to the commerce committee
um i will be brief my name is dan
bennett i'm with the new hampshire auto
dealers association
um i'm the vice president of our
government relations so
nhada is a trade association
representing the motor vehicle industry
we have over 500 members we are car
trucks snowmobile atv
construction farm equipment body shops
pretty much if it's got an engine and
wheels or tracks we'll take it
and we are both franchised and
independent members and we're very proud
of the fact that
uh we actually represent more
independent members than
um franchise folks so um
we employ about 14 000 citizens in the
state of new hampshire
now we make up about 24 of the retail
sales
uh statewide we're led by our president
peter mcnamara
and we have an association staff of
about 30 employees
uh we're located right on the bow
concord line
short of the liquor commission i think
we are regulated by just about every
uh regulatory agency in the state of new
hampshire i don't need to go through the
uh the alphabet soup of acronyms but
mostly where we're in front of commerce
committees
for banking department and insurance
department issues
so uh that's why you see us shortly uh i
will email you all a fact sheet about
nhada that has contact information and
some statistics
but a few of the things that i just want
to point out very briefly are
we work on roadway safety issues with
the department of safety and dmv
we also work force is a critical issue
for us
uh we do a tremendous amount of
workforce issues with
uh over 25 high schools and community
colleges
um for both front end and back end jobs
uh in our industry whether it's sales
and finance
or the service department and we're very
proud of over the past
few years we've given away over four
hundred thousand dollars in scholarships
to students to get their careers and
educated sessions started
uh be it to pay for community colleges
or tools
um in the service department so
workforce again a critical issue
um for us in our industry um and then
lastly what i'd like to point out
um and there'll be some contact and some
information on the handout that i'll
send to you
is our auto cap program and auto cap is
the automotive
consumer action panel it's a panel that
we run
uh to help uh consumer disputes uh it'll
be very helpful for your constituents
uh the attorney general's office as
brandon mentioned
earlier today i know they refer about
200 calls to us
that most often it's a misunderstanding
the sales manager didn't know what
a salesman told a customer or the
customer didn't know what tires for life
really meant so just by engaging them in
communication we find that we can
resolve a number of disputes
if the consumer's not happy they still
have the ability to go to small claims
court through the court system
the the the member the dealer the
decision of this
uh independent arbitration panel it's
binding on them
and if they don't follow it we have and
we can and we we will
throw them out of our association so we
take it very very seriously
um i believe the auto cap will be a
great resource for you if you do have a
constituent and consumer complaint
so um i'll kind of don't want to stand
any further between you and lunch
um i'll end it there but just to mention
that we look forward to working with you
if there's anything that we can assist
on please do not hesitate to reach out
to us
and we hope to see you soon in person
great thank you dan that was excellent
all right
next up is kathy corey
i am now promoting you kathy we're we're
down
to about eight names left here
we're getting there
are you there kathy i can hear
footprints i hear
people walking
are you there
[Music]
how's that good okay yeah we got you
sorry about that
technology good afternoon mr chair
members of committee and happy new year
it's nice to see all of you all though
virtual um
kathy fox i'm with the bernstein shore
group uh we have a variety of clients
but most particular clients that are
interested in your committee are
martin any companies of northern new
england um distributors of fine wine and
spirits and they are located in the
beautiful milliard in manchester
we also work with uber technology which
i'm sure you're familiar with there
vehicles for hire a ride share and uh
also their food delivery known as
ubereats
um we have again a variety of other
clients
that are interested in commerce but
those the two primary
um look lunchtime is here i thank you
for this opportunity i look forward to
seeing
each and every one of you in person
hopefully soon and i wish you all the
best this session thank you very much
great thank you very much uh next
up is bruce berkey
and you're on bruce
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee it's uh my pleasure to
to be with you here the this afternoon
um
my name is bruce berkey uh i'm with
sheehan vinnie capital group and you
heard from
my partner henry value a little bit
earlier today
and we have a variety of clients that
are are very interested in issues that
come before the house commerce committee
uh they include equifax on uh
privacy and and issues of that nature
the national federation of independent
business they are a small business group
of over a thousand members here in new
hampshire
dealing with you know business issues
and regulatory issues
delta dental is a regulated entity by
the state of new hampshire as
an insurance carrier
the chain drug stores here in new
hampshire uh are a client of ours
and also ski new hampshire uh ski new
hampshire is
is uh uh active in front of several
committees and
and uh you know they're having a
challenging year but
things are going pretty well with the uh
guidance visiting guidance has been
structured
uh through the state so with that i wish
you a a good legislative session and
look forward to seeing you either
virtually or in person soon thank you
great thank you bruce all right next up
is simon
thompson all right simon you're on
good morning uh chairman hunt and
members of the house commerce committee
uh that that the timing is ironic i too
am with uh she and finney capital group
and and work with bruce berkey
and henry value as well as a few others
in our in our shop this afternoon i'll
just mention a couple of key clients
that i specifically work on a majority
of the time
and then let you folks move on to begin
with uh anheuser-busch
is one of our clients as many of you
know there is
a brewery and hazard bush has a brewery
in the town of merrimack
just this past year 2020 they celebrated
their 50th
anniversary uh brewing uh the most
popular beer in the world
so we will come before your committee on
occasion
uh and as well as another client in the
liquor
realm as well as tobacco and others is
the new england
convenience store and energy marketers
association
nexum talk about a mouthful they are the
trade association that represents the
convenience stores as well as the
businesses that deliver
the fuel to those convenience stores so
we will be coming before your committee
on a whole host of issues
with regard to community stores and then
two more
one in the insurance realm pia
professional insurance agents of new
hampshire the
they're the independent insurance agent
owners association
they come before your committee on a
fair
fairly regular basis and a kind of along
the lines of
security telecommunications verizon
wireless
along with bruce berkey i represent
verizon wireless as well so you'll
you'll on occasion see us
on behalf of that client look forward to
working with you all in 2021
and i will sign off thank you okay
thank you uh no
okay what's up sabrina dunlap
i am promoting you up
okay hopefully
hi everybody hi hi
i'm sabrina dunlap i am the director of
government relations at anthem
uh many of you might know paula rogers
who was in this role for many years and
paula is still thankfully around still
involved with anthem and
um working with me as well so you will
probably see paula
as well this session which is great um
and anyway just looking forward to
working with you all
thanks so much okay thank you
uh nick chrono
uh
okay nick you're on
good afternoon everybody uh just paula
i'm with the new hampshire
hospital association um paula minihan
did a good job summarizing what we do
specifically i'm the director of
financial policy and reimbursement so
as that pertains to our member hospitals
that's really why i spend a lot of time
in the commerce committee so i look
forward to the session this year thanks
everybody
okay thank you yeah i guess uh my
editorialization is that
um often when it comes to insurance
reimbursements you're dealing with
hospitals and
so hence why the hospitals are visiting
us and also at merger
production the issue of mergers it comes
to us
okay so uh i just
i just while i'm talking i just promoted
somebody
uh was it you liz beth
did i just promote you
can you hear me yes
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is beth
sargent i too work for sheehan finney
capital group
the reason i would be before your
committee would be that i represent the
new hampshire pharmacists association
and also the new hampshire society of
health system pharmacists
who are pharmacists in hospitals i also
represent the new hampshire funeral
directors association
and the new hampshire academy of
audiology um
and those are audiologists um on a side
note
clients i represent who are mo not
usually before your committee
uh the new hampshire association of
chiefs of police and the new hampshire
sheriff's association
once in a great while we have something
before you so i look forward to
working with you and if we can be
assistants we're happy to be so
thank you okay great thank you um so
now i have four more attendees but they
didn't raise your hand so i don't know
uh jim monahan or jamie okay
no no so you if you you yeah all right
so i got
lindsay his radio stream okay perfect
where's george lindsey hello mr chairman
thank you for having me george wasn't
able to come but i'm sure you'll be
hearing from him
it's nice to see so many familiar faces
and so many new faces
my name is lindsey nato i'm a concord
native i work at the law firm or in reno
just down the street from the state
house
as mentioned i work with george russos
who you will probably get to know if you
don't know already
we primarily appear before house
commerce for insurance clients
and that runs the line from property and
casualty insurance
life insurance to health insurance so
for example we
represent the new hampshire association
of domestic insurance companies
the national trade the american property
casualty insurance association
and we also also represent cigna on the
healthcare company
so we look forward to working with you
and we're here to be a resource so if
there's anything we can help with
please don't hesitate to let us know
thank you
okay great thank you all right jim
monahan
all right you're on jim
we're getting down there
ah great chairman hunt thank you uh i'll
just be brief because susan paschall
from our office
at the dupont group ran through a number
of our clients i just wanted to
um put a name with the face um and um
um i'm looking forward to spending some
virtual time with the commerce committee
this session
thank you all right great thank you all
right so i have two other names but
you guys jamie and teresa you didn't
raise your hand so i assume
you didn't really feel need to share
introduce yourselves which is fine
so otherwise to the rest of the
committee that is it and you can
need to say um i wish you could say well
that's all the lobbyists but there are a
lot more out there that
that do come in front of the committee
um sometimes our exec sessions it uh
it's amazing how many people we can pack
into the room
uh from all the different industries and
variety of things that we do
so um with that um i
thank you all very much and
feel free to call me if you have any you
know suggestions or comments or
how this is working and what we can do
um i i'm
you know this is a new experience for
for me for sure
and uh so we're trying to try our best
if
i do if get permission to schedule bills
you will get notification from from
heather
usually sends out the notification and
then of course the calendar so
for your new members i wanna i cannot
emphasize enough that on thursday night
um they put out the calendar and you you
definitely wanna read it see what's in
there
uh see what's going on on other
committees um
and they also have a senate count
separate calendar if you want to track
bills that are going on in the senate
and
not screw up like i didn't forget not
know that senate commerce was being
monday where i should have been tuning
in to watch
uh but nothing else you can get
everything now
and you can see this it's all over again
uh on
on youtube and so uh which is uh
uh amazing phenomena that i guess that
was one of the positives
from this covet is that we now have this
technology
um to to record all these these uh
these meetings so uh feel free to go
back and revisit
uh there's a lot of stuff we got we
covered today and a lot of people
um and uh so we've got a lot to think
about over the weekend
otherwise uh have a good uh martha
luther king weekend
and uh and we'll hopefully see you all
next week or the or soon enough
bye bye everybody